peu
[Musique]
pendant france d'en bas
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle l'émission que ma mère
préfère avec nous ce soir
bruno des langes et le français rescapé
your world trade center
franck dubosc avant son zénith marie
noëlle lienemann
l'ex ministre de jospin qui balance sur
son ancien patron
david habib et mig et skoda pour meurtre
au vatican dont personne n'en parle
olivia bonamy yann moix pour podium le
roman de la rose et philippe corti pour
tout le monde écoute notre fameuse ligne
destin
j'accueille notre premier invité bruno
del angers
[Musique]
willow des ingés bonsoir on est à sainte
foy les lyon il y à 41 ans parcours
départ assez classique école de commerce
diplôme
et puis dans les années 80 vous créer
une radio libre avec jean edern hallier
exact ensuite entre deux petits boulots
vous écrivez un livre où vous évoquez
des tours de cristal qui disparaissent
dans l'apocalypse est vrai c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est la conclusion même du
livre puisque c'est une immense vision
de l'apocalypse qui clôture ce ce
premier livre et je les voyais comme un
symbole de new york bien sûr
prémonitoire
peut-être mais la grande aventure de
lundi justement c'est l'amérique d'abord
la californie ensuite new york
vous adhérez au rêve américain et en
1997 vous fonder une société destinée à
aider les sociétés américaines qui
veulent investir en europe et
inversement
également vous organiser des expositions
pour de jeunes artistes américains
vous installez vos bureaux au 47e étage
du wall trade center ces bureaux vous
les adorez
je les adore vous dites une transparence
des murs en verre une table en verre un
lieu de paix de sérénité de réflexion
dans ce dans cette ville de new york est
une ville extrêmement bruyante
c'était un lieu où il y avait un silence
merveilleux presque magique
les gens qui étaient dans les étages
supérieurs par exemple vous pouvez
passer l'hiver entier dans les nuages
dans le coton et nous on était à la
bonne à la bonne hauteur c'est à dire
qu'on avait parfois le coton aussi mais
parfois on était aussi au dessus des
nuages
souvent on était
dans un soleil radieux comme le temps
new yorkais alors le soir des fois vous
quittez votre bureau du wall trade
center vous marchez sur le pavillon vous
vous retournez et vous dites c'est pas
vrai [ __ ] je suis dans le wall trade
center complètement à wall trade centers
on parlait très bien dans votre livre
parce qu'en fait c'est une ville en
l'air il ya énormément de gens qui
équilibre là dedans c'est une utopie des
gens de toutes les races de toutes les
classes de toutes les religions 115
nationalités et qui vivait
harmonieusement
et puis un jour ce jour c'est le 11
septembre 2001 comme vous dites
les [ __ ] ils ont pété mon bureau
interview vérité
[Musique]
alors bruno ménager lançait pts ambre
2001 votre réveil sonne à 4 heures du
matin pourquoi parce que victoria un
déplacement professionnel et elle va à
saint paul minneapolis et elle part très
tôt elle parle l'aéroport de newark dans
le new jersey tout un certain nombre
d'avions ont décollé au sinon un avion
suicide moi je me lève vers 6h30 alors
veut faire victoria est parti pour
pousser à faire vous vous prenez votre
métro normalement pour rejoindre le
world trade center et à 8h45 vous êtes
avec vos deux employés vous commencez
votre journée de travail
le stagiaire est en retard oui un arnaud
ares et les trains du du nord de new
york du coin et les quêtes journée
normale je suis en est merveilleuse et à
ce moment là vous entendez vous dites
dans votre bouquin un énorme
vrombissement vous reconnaissez tout de
suite le bruit d'un avion
oui parce que je voyage beaucoup et
encore une fois la une des magies de ce
lieu c'était le silence
donc je le remarque immédiatement
comprenez pas sur le moment vous relevé
la tête et au moment vous relevé la tête
vous entendez un impact d'une violence
inouïe et trois secondes plus tard vous
voyez passer par la fenêtre devant vous
oui les débris débutera elle vous voyez
sub médusés je vois passer devant devant
mes fenêtres et 2
et mes employés sont médusés aussi on
voit passer des tonnes d'oeufs de
morceaux de ferraille de kérosène de
verre et on sait pas ce que c'est on
comprend pas mais très inquiet à ce
moment là non non non parce que le
bâtiment hausse il vraiment très très
longuement il tente pendant une
vingtaine de secondes 30 secondes je
sais pas exactement et à tel point que
je suis obligé de tenir une de mes
employés parce que j'ai peur qu'elle
s'effondre et dans le bureau tout bouge
les tableaux un tableau se casse la
figure une statue est vraiment va si
fortement mais non on n'a pas peur on
pense que je le redis g7 remarque idiote
je leur dis vous inquiétez pas c'est un
avis ans qui a percuté le bâtiment
ouais oui parce qu'en 45 à une erreur de
pilotage avait amené déjà un avion à
s'écraser contre le land ailleurs state
building je ne sais pas oui oui c'est à
ça que je penserais immédiatement et je
me dis c'est un avion un pilote qui a
qui a mal mais je pense pas un avion de
ligne certainement pas et je pense pas à
un attentat en quoi - ouais ouais
notre seule réflexion ce qu'on l'a si
vous dire c'est qu'on va perdre des
journées de travail parce que vous êtes
un entrepreneur vous êtes en amérique
n'est pas pris évidemment conscience de
l'ampleur du drame
et puis à ce moment là un de vos
employés ouvre la porte qui donne sur le
couloir et à ce moment là quand même
vous voyez de la fumée se sentent
kérosène oui alors que notre bureau
était dans un état tout à fait
acceptable on ouvre la porte et là c'est
déjà une certaine dévastation parce que
les
les plafonds sont effondrés il ya de la
fumée
il ne donne kérosène épouvantable plus
tard quand j'ai vaincu ray il ya même
des l'eau qui coule dans les dents dans
les cages d'ascenseur de service
ouais on voit pas très bien il ya
quelqu'un qui s'enfuit dans la pénombre
et mes employés ont ont peur parce que
c'est une femme qui a eut subi
l'attendent à 93 et quand je leur dis de
partir d'un ils suivent immédiatement
cette ça alors vous rester seul dans le
bureau vos employés sont descendus 1
alors assez tranquillement d'ailleurs
vous faites vos sauvegardes
informatiques vous raccrochez vos
tableaux vous éteignez la photocopieuse
c'est bien je faisais le tour ouais je
fais le tour je coupe tout et je fais
une sauvegarde informatique mais mettez
de l'ordre dans votre bureau vous dit
tiens je vais rester plusieurs jours
sans revenir donc voilà je veux que ça
soit bien que ce soit à que se soit
rangée et alors on n'entend rien parce
que les haut parleurs ne marchait par
les haut-parleurs d' alerte sur le 47e
étage en était en train de refaire les
les systèmes d'alarmé
donc je n'ai pas de sentiment d'urgence
immédiate vous prenez l'escalier assez
tranquillement au bout d'un moment il ya
47 étages à descendre évidemment la
descendre la durée 50 minutes sans
beaucoup d'affolement d'ailleurs
effectivement les gens ben un petit peu
comme moi je trouve qu'ils ont une
journée de travail interrompu trouve ça
désagréable mais tout le monde est très
calme très civique très ordonnée et en
descend
le landais les 47 étages pendant que les
trafics qui se densifie
pas de panique les gens parlent des
affaires en cours il maquille et
commente les résultats sportifs de la
veille comme voilà comme ça
à un moment il ya un type quand même qui
reçoit un texto qui lui annonce que la
tour numéro deux a été attaquée mais
personne panique les gens continuent à
descendre
il ya quand même un truc un peu plus
inquiétant au monde c'est quand vous un
brûlé vous double et là vous dites dans
votre bouquin les gens détournent assez
pudiquement le regard
oui et je pense que ça fait partie de
ces mécanismes de défense qu'on a tous
eu dans des circonstances difficiles
on voulait peut-être pas voir ce qui se
passait et puis en plus on comprenait
pas parce que ces gens étaient n'avait
plus de poney plus de cheveux étaient
complètement brûlé et tout au long de la
tour dans les escaliers de c'est tout on
entendait s'écrit priorité priorités et
les gens descendent des blessures en
priorité les pieds des pompiers qui
montrent aussi harnachés alors
évidemment il ya une espèce de va et
vient comme ça dans ses escaliers mais
tout ça est avec beaucoup de calme comme
on l'a dit vous arrivez sur le parvis du
wall trade center oui je suis sorti en
souterrain les gens qui sont sortis sur
le parvis et qui était parti en même
temps que moi
eux sont décédés donc je suis sorti en
souterrain en sortant dans la rue je me
suis retourné j'ai vu ce bâtiment en feu
là j'ai compris que c'était très grave
et puis effectivement je me suis
retourné une deuxième fois et je n'ai
pas vu ce que ce monstre kim qui
arrivait sur nous le nuage tueur le
killer klout le nuage ce tueur est ce
que j'appellerais plus tard aussi
vraiment le baiser de la mort et c'est
parce que ça dépasse l'entendement en un
instant alors que dans cette rue il y
avait une vie extraordinaire de services
de secours qui étaient dans tous les
sens de voitures de d'ambulances de
gyrophares partout de sirène soudain
s'abat sur nous cette masse monstrueuse
et tout devient silencieux et c la nuit
et donc là à ce moment là l'esprit est
plus capable de
procéder à l'analyse et c'est le
subconscient qui reçoit tout quand on
est terrorisé et maintenant je comprends
ce que c'est qu'un traumatisme
parce que ça dépend seulement se dépasse
tellement l'entendement que le cerveau
est plus capable de l'accepter
ce nuage il avait quelque consistance
moi j'appelle ça de la matière fluide
parce qu'il ya une accumulation
extrêmement dense de cendres de débris
de gravats de poutrelles de verre j'ai
gardé la cendre que j'ai recueilli
sûrement sur mon costume ce que je
considère qu'elle est sacrée et
qu'effectivement dans toute cette cendre
il ya peut-être des morceaux d'hommes
alors à ce moment là vous vous réfugier
derrière le pilier d'une banque vous
êtes tout noir évidemment couverts de 2
c de cette chose quoi de cette matière
fluide comme vous dites vous êtes plus
d'oxygène peut plus respirer parce
qu'évidemment ce nuage a envahi toute
l'atmosphère
vous croyez être mort en fait à ce
moment là - où mon subconscient est
persuadé que je suis mort et alors ça se
traduira par des choses invraisemblables
parce que un petit peu plus tard quand
je me promène dans la rue mon esprit
continuer à capter des signaux de ce que
la vie continue mais à l'intérieur lui
persuadé des morts alors j'ai
l'impression de devenir complètement fou
et j'ai l'impression que quand on parle
de ces gens qui sont devenus amnésiques
en a retrouvé un il ya quelques jours
seulement
je comprends tout à fait ce qui s'est
passé ils ont juste pas résisté
n'hésitez pas loin ben moi j'ai cru
vraiment devenir un parfait
alors là il ya un agent du fbi à qui
vous fait entrer dans la banque bâloise
est de sauver vous retrouvez d'autres
gens d'ailleurs maintenant qu'ils sont
aussi noir que vous alors là évidemment
il ya les bons sentiments on a beaucoup
parlé ici aux etats-unis dans les médias
mais aussi vous découvrez la nature
humaine c'est à dire qu'il ya des
profiteurs il ya des pilleurs il ya des
vautours
on vous propose par exemple un jour des
bureaux gratuit c'est vachement content
on y tient les mecs sont solidaires ils
m'offrent des bureaux gratuit et le type
vous dis que ça c'est valable pendant
deux mois et qu'à partir de la fin du
deuxième mois il faudra payer 2000
dollars par poste de travail
ce qui fait beaucoup d'argent en tous
les cas beaucoup plus cher que ce que
vous payez ual trade center c'est
difficile de découvrir sept
aspect si la nature humaine enfin c'est
pas une découverte non plus mais les
hommes sont les hommes et simplement
dans ces circonstances ça prend un
relief particulier effectivement alors
tu ça en plus dans une psychose terrible
un état de guerre quoi peur de l'anthrax
à ce moment-là vous chercher avec
victoria votre épouse des masques à gaz
sur internet en fin de journée c'est
presque un sentiment de vengeance vous a
aidé à ce moment là au début j'ai eu une
haine violente pour tous ces gens
maintenant c'est le mépris et rien de
plus ben laden vous l'auriez tués
ben laden je pense que tous mes idéaux
ont volé en éclats et que j'ai pu aucune
certitude aujourd'hui sur ce que c'est
que sur la punition qu'on doit infliger
à des gens pareils et que je croyais que
les idéaux c'était éternelle et j'étais
contre la peine de mort et maintenant je
me pose de sérieuses questions
oui parce que on peut pas se laisser
traiter comme ça c'est pas possible
vous trouvez normal le sort que les
américains réserve aux prisonniers de la
base de guantanamo par exemple moi je
trouve que si c'est des criminels il
s'est encore bien traités parce que
quand on affiche tant de souffrances aux
gens on prend ses responsabilités
d'abord et on les assume jusqu'au bout
brasser qui mérite la façon dont on les
traite
je pense qu'ils n'ont pas volé la guerre
en afghanistan et y est pour les
bombardements de civils ou pas pour la
gaine mais après j'ai compris que
c'était important de répondre et je
crois que je me suis sentie rassurée
rassuré de ce que les gens qui sont
supposés nous défendre nous défende
et oui je pense qu'elle était nécessaire
ce biais pour moi y ait aucun doute
c'est vrai qu'un an après les attentats
du world trade center l'antiaméricanisme
n'a jamais été aussi fort en europe 55 %
des européens jugent le comportement
américain pas étranger à ces attentats
c'est beaucoup 55 % des européens en
france et 63 % des gens qui pensent non
pas que les américains n'ont pas volé
c'est un peu exagéré mais que leur
comportement est pas étranger aux
attentats oui je trouve quelque chose de
monstrueux là dedans parce que comment
un très rapidement
quand on dit ils n'ont pas volé vraiment
on oublie en oublie tout ce qui s'est
passé et il n'y a pas d'actes
il n'y a pas de cause il n'y a pas de
défense de causes qui justifie un acte
pareil voici que c'est une attitude
munich oise je pense qu'il ya certains
roland munichois dans tout ça et je
pense que on est très injuste à l'égard
des états unis parce que ils prennent
des responsabilités souvent que le monde
refuse de prendre
et après tout les européens ont des
idéaux et il faut prendre les moyens de
les défendre finalement alors vous savez
qu'on soupçonne l'arabie saoudite de
financieele qaïda sur les 19 pirates y
en avait 15 qui étaient saoudiens
mais les usa évidemment ne peuvent pas
s'en prendre à l'arabie saoudite aussi
directement les familles des victimes le
fond les familles des victimes du 11
septembre ont attaqué au tribunal des
banques saoudiennes des organisations
caritatives et trois membres de la
famille royale est ce que ça remet pas
en cause
votre attachement au système américain
de voir que finalement leur vrai demi
ils ont pratiquement identifié mais que
pour des raisons mercantiles
ils peuvent pas s'y attaquer parce que
l'arabie saoudite al pétrole oui vous
savez et je pense que c'est pas le
système américain qui est en cause en
saut dans cette histoire c'est l'intérêt
des états et on sait que les états
parfois se conduisent pas forcément
comme ils le souhaitent et le rêve
américain ou où tout ce qui est ça n'a
rien à voir
je crois à l'heure actuelle que
effectivement tout le monde y compris
nous en europe sommes bien heureux
d'avoir cette source d'approvisionnement
pétrolière donc c'est du réalisme
c'est à la réalité qu'on appelle le
réalisme politique
vous êtes d'accord avec ce qui est prévu
à la place du wall trade center sur ce
qui s'appelle aujourd'hui ground zero
aujourd'hui je suis je suis un peu déçu
parce qu'ils étaient présentés oui parce
que effectivement ça n'a pas l'élan
cavell de rochester pour moi le world
trade center tout le monde a vu comme un
symbole de domination là encore et de
puissance américaine c'était un témoin
du du génie humain et et on verra les
concours sont pas encore terminées je
pense que tout le monde va se remettre
sur la planche à dessin
si les tours sont reconstruites à cet
endroit là vous retournerez vous y
installer immédiatement
ah oui immédiatement parce que j'ai un
grand attachement au lieu je crois que
ce serait bien de pouvoir retourner là
bas
et puis une vue magnifique oui vous
ferez quoi là en septembre
le 11 septembre je voudrais avec ceux
qui m'ont aidé d'abord l'un qui ont vécu
ça j'aimerais aussi revoir les deux
femmes qui qui m'ont aidé quand
je suis revenu du world trade center
j'étais complètement couvert de cendres
j'étais hébété
je ressemblais un fantôme et je voyais
bien devant moi tout le monde s'écarte
et et moi je rêvais que d'une chose
c'est que les gens me prennent dans
leurs bras
et puis personne s'approchait bien sur
mes skis c'est tout on avait peur et je
me rappelle que à un moment sur broadway
deux femmes noires sont un projet de moi
et je vois très bien dans quel magasin
et le travail sont approchés de moi et
puis ils m'ont fait rentrer elles m'ont
donné un verre d'eau puis ensuite elles
m'ont dit vas-y appel viens on va
composer le numéro pour toi et un
simplement l on appelait appelé appelé
puis en pas réussi à appeler ni victor
est un animal en donc ces femmes là
j'aimerais revoir le vrai ce temps vous
arrivez à vivre avec ça on vous
maintenant j'arrive à vivre avec ça en
moi c'est pas facile parce que c'est
comme un invité que vous avez vous
n'avez pas sollicité et il se manifeste
selon son son bon gré mais est ce assez
c'est horrible merci ça s'appelle
20h40 7e étape et c'est chez robert
laffont
[Musique]
tél
m
j'accueille maintenant franck dubosc
[Musique]
bonsoir
alors franck gros gros succès cette
année vous êtes le seul à avoir fait à
la fois le casino de paris l'olympia et
bientôt le zénith
sans compter évidemment en tournée dans
toute la france en belgique en suisse et
la réunion au canada l'homme sait
maintenant pour les gens qui font un
triomphe dans cette émission on a un
nouveau truc c'est un vidéo sans pleurs
revoilà les trions le crillon de 30 du
boeuf méline s'il vous plaît est-ce
qu'on pourrait apporter à franck dubosc
son collier de superstar voilà
ouais ça sait où va très bien en france
je crois qu'effectivement ah oui c'est
un peu rappeur de los angeles mais bon
c'est de l'argent massif alors franck on
va pas revenir sur votre légende la
naissance dans la dans la banlieue de
rouen au grand-quevilly les premières
marionnettes payer 20 centimes dans la
cour de la celle m les parodies
d'émissions télé le conservatoire de
rouen où vous côtoyez valérie lemercier
karin viard virginie lemoine avec qui
vous jouez d'ailleurs des petits sketchs
dans des boîtes de nuit et jean-philippe
joubert et voilà jean vazel
jean-philippe joubert bien attention
quand il ya vingt ans vous avez à paris
vous passé cinq ans dans une chambre de
bonne de 9 m² j'étais quand même à
l'angle de rivollier de la concorde
quand même c'était pareil enfin sans wc
sans eau chaude et effet comment j'ai
j'ai beaucoup je vais beaucoup plus et
ouais nan nan pendant 58 au bout d'un
moment s'habitue à loder et vous y êtes
fait quoi ouais spécifique en 1984 vous
entrez dans la carrière du cinéma avec à
nous les garçons et puis vous partez en
angleterre où vous devenez ce french
lover dans une série culte des anglais
qui s'appelle comme un nation street
un feuilleton très connus regardez là
bas par 22 millions de gens une énorme
star en angleterre vous revenez en
france mais dans dans mon 9 mètres
carrés
mais je crois qu'on peut le dire la
blessure est mal cicatrisées pour le
peuple britannique et nous avons
retrouvé un document qui en dit long sur
le mal que vous leur avez fait franck
magnier théo serge force nous est de
reconnaître non depuis l'année au franck
dubosc a quitté coronation street
ce pays n'a plus jamais été le même en
d'autres termes le plus affirmé au monde
entier que cette année là fut l'annus
horribilis
voilà le mal que vous avez fait à ce
pays
en partant on la sait rien là c'est rien
parce que ça c'est la mère le fils c'est
pire
magnéto serge on me dit que ce bâtard
fait l'olympia au casino de paris de ces
mêmes le zénith ce que je dis c'est
qu'il ferait mieux de rentrer revenir
ici ne se sont pas remis de votre départ
je suis désolé alors le prince charles
parlait du zénith de paris où vous serez
derrière les 4 5 et 6 octobre
et puis après vous faites tous les
zénith de france oui les grosses salles
quand ya pas de zenit voilà c'est à dire
les parcs exposition les bourses du
travail
enfin voilà c'est ça un peu bigard
maintenant non non non non non non je le
pack est beaucoup plus petit il est plus
costaud il sait des plus grosses
alors c'est ce spectacle a démarré en
octobre 2001 dont vous étiez venu nous
parler ici qui s'appelle je vous ai pas
raconté c'est toujours le même évolué
bien évidemment magnéto serge bon je
vous dis franchement j'ai j'ai baisé
mais je crois j'ai pas vraiment eu le
temps de me rendre compte ça dure huit
minutes montre en main vous montre ma
façon de parler bien évidemment j'avais
j'avais autre chose dans les mains
pardonnez mon souhait mon caméscope mans
oh là là une minute l'alava direct
direct à de préliminaires et indirects
pas bhl de roulage de pelle pilotage de
nibards touche-pipi mélange poil tout ça
tient bien à nana na na na na je suis
désolé mais rld a pourtant pour qui mme
koné avant il ya toujours un petit peu
de petites caresses bonjour mademoiselle
pop on y va un peu de ce que j'appelle
le pubis relais ch
nous quoi au à propos du pubis relation
ne sortait pas cette blague devant des
enfants a pas de bêtises
tous les enfants sont insensées et
parlez anglais un pote non les enfants
savent bien ce que c'est qu'un pubis là
n'est pas la question savent bien qu un
publiciste
c'est un type d'animal qui laisse des
pales sur le rebord des toilettes tap
et je peux vous dire que vous n'avez
jamais plu aux toilettes on pense à moi
alala une minute b says gt gt gt gt
j'avais honte tu t'es mal j'ai décrit
vous imaginez les mecs vous vous
rappelez même olalalala olp humeur de
sava héros quand on visite un
appartement qui nous plaît pas en reste
pas des heures de dents à hautmont
copain benoît benoît benoît c'est moi ce
que je n'avais pas de piles mon père
m'avait dit ah tiens par l'effort
ou façon c'est benoît il avait pas de
petit bol qui gamin c'était réglé y
avais tu vois qui attend un grand
quévilly un seul takeuchi la vie
la classe comme big boss musée pas
raconté dans un zénith psg ball
messieurs et le 4 5 et 6 octobre au
zénith de paris
alors paul du buzz que vous avez
beaucoup de chance on vous appelle le
playboy du rire
vous savez ça plus très playboy quand
même maintenant j'ai 25 ans je me suis
cassé la gueule ne pas vous casser la le
col du fémur apprend que ça serait
vraiment aidé à mon âge quand vous
faites gaulle et toute façon c'est avec
votre femme c'est ça qui est génial ça
quand tu vois si vous mais en photo
c'est avec sabrina donc leucatois de la
chance j'ai de la chance mais c'est bien
une chance de cocu eux ils en ont pas
l'année suivante c'est égal à donc après
voici c'est très beau papier la même
femme toujours un
ça fait quatre ans que ça dure ouais
bientôt un petit bébé tu crois que j'ai
mis le doigt sur un truc à la maison ça
doit à parler en ce moment là prendre
pourquoi pas maintenant si on le fait
pas maintenant
justement ces problèmes c'est quoi il
faudrait que j'arrête de mettre le doigt
sur un truc et je procède autrement
mais si peut-être oui oui certainement
mais c'est vachement dur quand on est
très égoïste quand on fait ce métier là
moi je avec tout ce qui m'est arrivé
cette année j'ai sûrement un peu trop
penser à moi et puis quand le spectacle
va s'arrêter bah je vais peut-être
penser que de mon corps se retire à la
graine qui qui à l'aide de sabrina
fabriquera le l'enfant que nous a pas
longtemps gelé sabrina ou une autre oui
mais
ça se passe bien oui c'est ça le
problème le problème c'est qu'elle
travaille chez endemol la boîte qui fait
star academy et et love story le soir
quand elles rentrent du travail qu elle
vous raconte sa journée de travail c'est
d'être épouvantable non non d'abord
parce qu'elle m'en parle pas trop denses
de touche on sait qu'elle est souvent au
téléphone normalement parle pas trop et
mais bon je la travaille tout le temps
mais vous auriez par mick qu'elle est un
vrai travail
nana elle est très bien là bas il faut
pas qu'elle tombe au chômage avaient
terrorisé
non mais elle noël est très épanouie la
liant l aime beaucoup son travail son
employeur elle elle est très à fond aux
dents dans sa non ce qui ce qui est
dommage c'est qu'elle pourrait gagner
beaucoup plus d'argent mais elle n'ose
pas le dire elle mais c'est dit voilà en
tous les cas ça marche très fort pour
vous il ya un truc a complètement foiré
franck faut le dire c'est le cinéma
la dernière fois que vous êtes venus ici
vous m'avez dit je suis en train
d'écrire par un film je l'aimais qui
viennent richard fils quatre filles
quatre filles pour christian fechner way
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé vous l'avez
dit d'accord je suis en fait venir est
ce qu'on est vraiment obligé de faire du
cinéma
non j'ai joué à tout le monde en ce
moment qu'il veut faire du cinéma tous
les gens qu'ils sont comiques à la
télévision ou sur scène le faire du
cinéma n'y a pas d'obligation il ya un
truc il ya une espèce de syndrome des
gens qui font du cinéma vis-à-vis des
comics de trouver que nous les mecs à la
télé c'est les ringards et l'asie est
doué machin alors au début ça peu vexé
et pierre leman donné on se retrouve
devant 4000 personnes dans une salle on
est bien il nous aime et applaudissent
0-0 ce que j'ai vraiment besoin de deux
d'être vexé parce qu'on appuie sa passe
je veux dire je vous l'avais dit j'ai
une femme que j'aime j'ai un métier que
j'aime j'ai un public qui en face alors
le cinéma suivie en tant mieux je m'en
fous un peu là tout de suite
alors cet été vous avez fait quoi parce
que vous avez bossé comme un malade vous
êtes payé un peu de bon temps
vous avez du gala on n'apprend pas grand
chose dans ce spot je suis allé au
canada je suis allé oui je suis allé au
canada pour
assaut commis un à cinq a commis excusez
moi c'est un problème avec le québec
aurait adoré que je suis je souhaite
aller je domine non à ceux commis sur la
pseudo mis ses sagas commis sacacomie
pas saquer commune et est alors et et
deux bars rien sur leurs vacances et
puis j'ai j'ai surtout j'ai travaillé
j'ai fait un show et je me casser la
gueule à recevoir du fémur
attention non mais qu'est ce que c'est
que ce nouveau plateau ce sont de
nouveaux sièges
oui bah voila j'ai fait succéder ancien
siège continue à recruter europe 1 quand
il dira pas mais j'ai quand même bien
pris un peu de vacances avoue marie
alors messieurs les à uzès voyage chez
des amis moi donc ça nous a coûté très
cher et pas de jeu de mots à faire non
ben non ça maroc non non non ah non
d'habitus passe les vacances sur le
yacht de marché et donc chez des amis
donc là ça nous a coûté
ça devait participer quand même pour les
courses vous avez un petit peu non 9 on
est invité chez des gens on n'est pas
invités jeu ça vous aviez jamais au
supermarché faire un peu les courses
pendant les courses au supermarché non
non non je ne sais pas ce que c'est
elles n'ont pas donné de date
c'est vrai je ne fais pas les courses
[Applaudissements]
années difficiles aussi franck parce que
c'est l'année où vous avez perdu votre
votre père il vous a vu réussir c'est
quand même pas mal parce que beaucoup de
gens qui n'ont pas eu cette chance d'une
certaine façon oui ma vu réussir mais il
a fourni il a j'ai du mal à parler de ça
alors il n'a pas vu l'olympia ouais donc
face à vous non non non mais c'est je
veux dire c'est ça mais ça me dérange
pas parce que c'est quelqu'un que que
j'aime beaucoup et le on est pas on
n'est pas que des mois je suis un rigolo
à la pêche d'un ferry revient c'est bien
mais j'ai surtout un grand professionnel
mais ces publics qui est très
professionnel il y en a qui vient qui
est clé qui me donne beaucoup mais on a
oui oui j'ai joué le soir comme plein de
genre le soir où il est mort j'ai joué
j'ai été dans le train et et ma maman
m'a appelé à 15h m'a dit voilà ça y est
j'ai dit d'accord et puis j'ai joué le
soir et puis je me suis effondrée après
mais j'ai joué comme jamais parce que le
savoir que le public ne le sait pas et
qui rit quand même et je sais pas
comment dire c'est un effet c'est un
phénomène
et je parle de mon père dans prévu dans
le spectacle en plus et j'ai une
réplique pendant un spectacle où je me
moque de mon père et je dis au public
chimiques mon père qui qui qui qui parle
des village people fait révéler et les
gens riaient ce que s'il vous plaît ne
vous moquez pas de mon père les gens
rient jeudi foutez vous de sa gueule il
est pas là ce soir
et dire ça ce soir là c'était très bien
je le dis je les dis quand même parce
que parce qu'il aurait engueulé que je
le dise pas dit que tu fais je vais pas
t'es pas là il m'a dit tu rigoles ou
quoi c'est un spectacle qui va donc je
les fais voilà
je t'aime papa et il le sait en bbox
le pire est à venir nous allons passer à
l'interview pour ou contre
[Musique]
franck dubosc
etes-vous pour ou contre les faux seins
je suis très très contre mais est ce que
vous êtes pour ou contre le mariage
d'isabelle adjani avec jean michel jarre
je m'en fous complètement
mais alors complètement
[Applaudissements]
pour ou contre le réchauffement de la
planète
au moment des vacances j'aime bien pour
ou contre une bonne bière pour relancer
l'économie
[Rires]
non bien sûr que non en contre quand
compteront pour contre la peine de mort
je ouais pourquoi faire la paix demeure
donc je dirais non j'ai vu ce que
c'était que de perdre quelqu'un et je
pensais ceux qui perdraient quelques
dents est ce que vous êtes franck dubosc
pour ou contre les trentenaires qui
chantent ils aux enfants des soirées
privées pour bien sûr aussi venu le
temps des rires plein je ne suis pas
content non
on attend le
d'aisance manger
un cadeau est ce que vous êtes franck
dubosc pour ou contre l'adoption des
enfants par des couples homosexuels oui
pour winamp ou rsa c'est un truc alors
là la question ne devrait même pas
exister monsieur est ce que vous êtes
pour ou contre l'adoption des
homosexuels par les enfants s'y sont
gentils oui est ce que vous êtes pour ou
contre le port des mocassins avec des
chaussettes blanches
alors si les chaussettes blanches ont
rayé bleu blanc rouge
oui qu'on les voit mais là je trouve que
ça le fait ça le vrai c'est bien place
avec des glands surtout les mocassins
avec les glorieux et enfin franck dubosc
h au delà maintenant est ce que vous
êtes pour ou contre
pour je vais pas raconter
le 4 et 5
6 octobre au zénith
et puis en tournée - de l'attendre
tél
bon enfant que bilan de cette interview
vous avez pensé quoi la promo ça allait
très bien je trouve que
qu'avec lâche thierry vous devenez
extraordinaire est excellent et
vous êtes l'animateur
qu'est ce que je dis aux autres
d'habitude vous êtes un des animateurs
les meilleurs de cette chaîne
vous aimez ça va ça va sur sabrina
j'étais bien ça allait sabrina c'est la
plus belle femme du monde les caisses
que je dis aux autres elle était très
bien on a pas dit on n'a pas dit que
j'aurais sûrement beaucoup de surprises
au zénith à des amis qui vont venir
voyez que ça sert les clients
l'interview certainement il ya de la
surprise
je pense qu'ils auraient de la surprise
il y aura peut-être un peu de fès ah y'a
pas durant l'hiver au moins non j'ai
parlé de fès
[Musique]
enfin ce maintenant notre rubrique tout
le monde s'en mêle
alors déjà quelques emails un email de
samira à thionville qui regrette qui est
pas eu des missions pendant l'été oh ben
alors d'habitude ya les best-of les
mêmes pas les best-of pourquoi pourquoi
vous prenez des vacances pour aller au
là que ça faisait comme il alors dans
kalaa d'orléans qui me demandent de
saluer gabriela de prilep en macédoine
qui nous regardent sur tv5 d'ailleurs en
parlant de tv5
je vous signale que la chaîne est
désormais diffusés à hong kong
tiens donc on ne voit partout je passe
au zénith de hong kong dans un spectacle
entièrement en c'est en mandarin dans la
norme de là bas au monde alain bauda
eh bien
ben pas signalé à saillat pour donc en
nageant marque qui nous voit sur sur tv5
et qui nous écrit un autre mail de
benoît du costa rica enfin bref tout le
monde en parle c'est vraiment le cas de
le dire c'est incroyable cette émission
alors du nouveau désormais vous
trouverez sur le site tout le monde en
parle
la liste des invités de la semaine
suivante ce qui vous permettra de leur
poser des questions voilà comme ça je me
serai votre intermédiaire chers amis
téléspectateurs comme on dit la
télévision
d'ailleurs ce soir et déjà des questions
pour olivia bonamy qui sera notre invité
tout à l'air voilà et puis dans cette
rubrique tout le monde s'en mêle
je vous entend également chaque semaine
des nouvelles de michaël blanc notre ami
michaël blanc qui est toujours en prison
à bali et qui n'a pas été libérés lors
de la fête nationale indonésienne le 17
août contrairement à ce qu'on croyait
avec son avocate sophie bottai voilà et
puis je vous donnerai aussi chaque
semaine des nouvelles de reporter sans
frontières qui est la cause que nous
avons décidé d'aider dans cette émission
voilà on en reparle la semaine prochaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cossette
et moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
ouais
je vous demande
de faire intrusion à la cour ghost
evanno que nous retrouverons toutes les
semaines sur le plateau de tout le monde
entende stefano cette chanson quant à
lui que la première version est sortie
juste et fin des années 70 même patti
labelle ggt j'étais tout jeune j'allais
en boîte et je me suis dans ce qu'on
attendait le refrain et vous coucher
avec moi pas laisser passer en face
d'une fille pour faire comme ça
généralement on se retrouve comme ça
puis dès que le refrain est arrivé à
pour lever la tête c'était un grand
black qui était pour vous la trouvez
comment nous y voilà
j'accueille maintenant notre invité
suivantes voici marie noëlle lienemann
[Musique]
langman bonsoir merci avec nous ce soir
de cette première émission de la saison
franck dubosc
bonsoir anne grand fan de la gauche
socialiste françois je crois qu'on peut
le dire
vous aviez dit qu'il aurait pas de sexe
dans cette émission sous les olé mais ça
commence plutôt bien alors lienemann
marie noëlle thérèse vous êtes né comme
lionel jospin 1 12 juillet mais vous
c'est en 1951 dans la ville de jean
pierre chevènement belfort
ça commence bien vous êtes marié à
patrice finel fonctionnaire membre lui
aussi des instances du ps
les deux enfants marianne 17 ans olivier
14 ans vous adhérez au parti socialiste
en 1971 à l'âge de 20 ans et 20 ans plus
tard en 1991 vous fendez la gauche
socialiste voilà un an plus tard vous
êtes ministre du logement dans le
gouvernement de pierre bérégovoy et vous
retrouvez ce ministère en 2001 à l'âge
de 50 ans dans le gouvernement jospin
temps passe est en passe aujourd'hui
vous n'êtes plus maire d'athis mons
dans l'essonne vous n'êtes pas député de
béthune où vous n'avez pas hésité à
faire campagne avec mellick l'ami de
bernard tapie ça vous dérange pas ça non
parce que jacques mellick a fait grosse
bêtise avec un faux témoignage
il a été condamné il a payé sa peine je
crois que dans notre société ce qui en
fait une bêtise n'ont pas à être banni
toute leur vie il a je prends aussi
beaucoup changé avec cette épreuve
et puis on a beaucoup de choses injustes
sur lui en particulier sur la corruption
et autres alors qu'on lui a pas mal
cherché de poux dans la tête
aucun fait autre que ce faux témoignage
mais lui a été reprochée et donc je n'ai
pas du tout le monde d'être à côté de
jacques mellick donc marie noëlle
lienemann vous publiez sheeran c'est un
livre qui s'appelle ma part d'inventaire
qui a foutu un beau bordel universités
d'été du ps à la rochelle remarqué
beaucoup n'ont pas été tellement surpris
par votre bouquin parce qu'on vous juge
impulsive
c'est vrai sans doute inclassable aussi
parce que j'aime pas trop classe et les
autres non plus incontrôlable ça c'est
moins vrai mais j'aime pas non plus être
très content je suis un tempérament
indépendance mais néanmoins toujours
inscrit dans un combat collectif et je
pense qu'on dit trop souvent que dans un
parti faut être complètement encadré ça
donne pas envie aux gens dignes de temps
pour les parties godillots - non non non
ça veut dire non 51 ans j'ai cherché
tout à l'heure
mais calculer alors henri emmanuelli a
dit bien avant la sortie de ce bouquin
il a dit en parlant de vous elle est
comme ces gosses que vous faites sauter
sur vos genoux pour les amuser et qu'il
vous pisse dessus
c'était en 92 depuis je crois que j'ai
grandi je pense que lui a aussi réfléchi
et ne dirai plus la même chose alors
plus sympathiquement michel field vous
comparent anémone et c'est vrai que
c'est quelque chose d'année c'est plus
sympathique non mais sans blague et ça
c'est vous le dis quelque chose dans le
look now et ensuite dans la semaine
c'est là qu'on parlait de foot j'aime
tout à fait quand je pense à lui je la
trouve très bien d'autant plus que j'ai
cru comprendre que elle s'engageait
beaucoup sur les questions d'écologie et
d'environnement être contestation de la
mondialisation libérale ça tombe bien
moi aussi alors lionel jospin est un
petit peu la tête de turc de ce livre à
ça commence par cette émission vous
dites la dignité c'est de ne pas
abandonner son camp en rase campagne
c'est vrai que lionel il est un peu fait
la même chose que giscard en 81 la
chaise vide
oui moi j'ai très mal vécu le soir où il
nous dit bon ben j'ai perdu donc
maintenant débrouillez vous tout seul
j'ai d'autant plus mal vécue que quand
il ya eu des élections législatives et
ben y avait un nouveau gouvernement qui
étaient là qui pouvait faire sa
publicité faire beaucoup d'effet
d'annoncé et affaiblir du cool combat
collectif de la gauche
et personnellement je pense que c'était
très important qu'après l'élection très
particulière de jacques chirac n'avait
pas été élu sur son programme
la grosse soit plus forte après moi le
déluge c'est ce que j'écris na li sans
donner de consigne de vote claire pour
le deuxième tour ça c'était l'autre
chose moi je fais partie des gens qu'on
peut hésiter une seconde
appelés à voter
pour jacques chirac parce que pour moi
le pen c'est l'ennemi absolu et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que cette défaite ne
doit pas rester sans un sens qu'on lève
les tabous du pourquoi on a perdu 30 %
des ouvriers ont voté le pen la gauche
peut pas faire semblant que c'est pas
une chose majeur on va en parler
françois mitterrand serait allé au bout
du combat je crois différence de carré
entre les deux car heures peut-être pas
caractère à coup sûr s'ignorent de
casting vous dites jospin c'est à dire
que comme premier secrétaire du parti ça
allait comme premier ministre ali n'est
peut-être qu'il avait pas là c'est vrai
qu'il n'est pas la dimension pour être
présent la république là je crois pas
qu'on puisse dire que quelqu'un la
dimension dans l'absolu je dis que quand
on était cinquante premiers ministres
qu'on n'a pas sorti le nez du guidon
qu'on est devant des situations on gère
au quotidien
eh ben je lionel jospin n'était plus
celui de 97 et il n'était pas assez
proche des français
comprendre ce qui n'allait pas leur
mécontentement vous dites en parlant de
lionel jospin qu'il a un égo
hypertrophié s'est pas dit ça moi j'ai
dit on le dit souvent de lui
alors oui on le vit souvent de lui oui
et je dis qu'on peut le comprendre parce
que comme c'est quelqu'un qui est un
rapport à lui même c'est pas négatif
forcément d'être face à sa conscience
quand on est un responsable
il est face à lui-même de ce qu'ils
pensent et par rapport à l'idée qu'il se
fait de sa conscience
alors c'est normal il faut avoir ça mais
en politique on n'est pas que soi-même
face à soi même on est là pour
représenter des gens être à l'écouté
d'un certain nombre de gens et là ça
suppose de dépasser ce côté grévistes
voilà plus tôt tout à fait
faites attention parce que les sièges
dont ils tiennent pas bien et tout à
l'heure ça y est vous avez pu remarquer
gilles massa je vous écoute et peu
importe que je me dis si elle tombe
trébuche mais je ne tombe parce que en
général
oh la la c'est une formule sa numéro
qu'on est ensemble qu'on est ensemble
paris noël le 4 5 et 6 octobre
oui oui ça m'a surpris modifié que
jospin est persuadé d'être plus
compétents que les autres c'est vrai
bien sûr de lui je trouve
je pense qu'il est assez confiant dans
son jugement ça peut être une qualité ça
peut être un défaut selon les périodes
et puis alors le phénomène de cour
dénoncé en son temps par claude allègre
d'ailleurs schrameck on maître de
cérémonie jospin enfermé dans sa tour
d'ivoire dites-vous bunkérisé
lui à matignon geneviève jeunes d
exemple un mois je me rappelle avoir une
réunion où j'explique que dans ma
commune de l'essonne où j'étais élu
quand un jeune fait des dividendes a
fait des bêtises
il est convoqué par le tribunal qui
l'orientent vers un éducateur qu'on
appelle de prévention de judiciaire de
la jeunesse délai entre le moment où il
est convoqué au tribunal et la première
réunion avec l'éducateur neuf mois je
j'explique on ne peut pas dire à nos
concitoyens que les problèmes de
sécurité notamment de la violence des
mineurs est correctement traités quand
tout le monde c'est sur le terrain que
neuf mois entre le moment où un gamin
fait une bêtise lourde quand même
puisque déjà la justice et où il est
convoqué par un éducateur
j'ai des tas d'exemples entre l'énorme
écart entre ce qu'on annonce est ce que
les gens vivent
je me suis occupé des hlm ont dit on
fait des grands programmes de rénovation
et au bout de 4 5 ans le premier crédit
n'est pas encore consommée les gens ont
des vous l'avez vu avec les ascenseurs
donc ce décalage avec le réel est déjà
un problème entre dans la politique et
encore plus quand autour de vous vous
n'est que des gens qui vous disent que
tout va bien de votre politique est
génial et c'est un pessimiste entourée
d' autiste et c'est vrai que vous dites
qu'il est très optimiste par rapport à
lui même mais pas tellement sur la
situation de la gauche en france pas
très optimiste il pense toujours que la
france n'est pas de gauche et que la
gauche peut arriver au pouvoir par
miracle donc a priori c'est pas un
enthousiasme c'est clair oui moi j'ai
toujours été frappé de ça c'est vrai que
mitterrand avait déjà ce côté la gauche
et pas majoritaire c'est grâce à moi
qu'on gagne c'est vrai que dans les
années 90 quand les grandes idées
libérales la chute du communisme tout ça
les bases assez historique de la gauche
ont été branlante comme moment le disco
aussi
mais je pense que la gauche avait quand
même une histoire plus long que le disco
commencé quand même bien avant en tout
cas des dépôts selon moi moi en tout cas
ce que je veux dire par là c'est qu'au
moment où ces idées là se sont un peu en
difficulté
eh bien il ya un espèce de pessimisme en
dix ans les gens sont plus de gauche ils
vont tous et pour le capitalisme pour le
fric pour le chacun pour soi
moi je ne le crois pas sa tournée j'ai
justement et c'est pour ça que je suis
une plus en rage fait que je me dis oh
moment les idées changent dans les têtes
les grandes manifs de seattle les gens
commencent à trouver que les placements
boursiers il n'y a pas que ça au monde
et c'est à ce moment là
la gauche n'est pas forte ne dit pas un
message clair du fait qu'on veut plus de
cette société bien sûr de façon
réformiste pour changer abandonne cette
idée là et en même temps traite de mon
beauf une bonne partie de la classe
ouvrière et là c'est le pen qui monte
dans ces sacs
mais ce qui nous a vraiment énervé c'est
quand d'abord jospin annonce sa
candidature par par fax 1 et le
lendemain il dit à la télé mon projet
n'est pas socialiste
la belle erreur en fait parce que lui il
a voulu rassembler dès le premier tour
et en politique on le sait mitterrand
très bien au premier tour d'abord son
camp oui
l'ensemble de la société deuxième tour
et commencé en disant avoir honte son
drapeau dans la poche
moi je pense que c'est pas une bonne
méthode et je peux vous dire je suis
pété la seule à mal le vivre c'est l'
influence de fabius dominique strauss
kahn
je crains que ce soit plus l'affluence
des sondages il y avait comme une sorte
de honte affirmé qu' on était de gauche
et je pense que c'est cette idée des
sondages et de la presse qui vous dit à
longueur de journée vous êtes au centre
faut être bien c'est quand on nous
annonce qui va baisser les impôts la
presse dit c'est fort mais c'est
formidable
or 120 milliards de baisses d'impôts aux
élections municipales suivantes la
gauche à une dégelée d'enfer dans tous
les quartiers populaires donc quand même
ça coûte cher ça rapporte pas gros quand
même ce genre de choix les problèmes ça
a été les 35 heures parce que finalement
mal appliquée on peut dire même si
l'idée au départ était valable c'est pas
possible il crée donc ça remis en cause
se défend les 35 heures d'abord c'est un
mouvement historique
ce qui est dramatique c'est que nous
nous a fait croire que pour avoir les 35
heures fallu ouvrir la boîte de pandore
de la flexibilité
annualisation du temps de travail des
ouvriers qui touchait des heures
supplémentaires les fonds mais ne sont
plus payés parce qu'on les comptes leurs
heures dans l'année donc leurs salaires
baissent alors que notre engagement
c'était 35 heures sans baisse de salaire
donc pour ma part je crois que c'est une
des grosses erreurs parce que on a
baissé le salaire des gens qui
travaillent et il faut valoriser la
valeur travail
première erreur deuxième erreur vous
dites l'insécurité sears et le fameux
discours de guigou relayée par les
droits de l'hommistes minimiser le
problème de l'insécurité elle conçoit
mal à l'aise pour savoir comment trouver
des solutions je crois que c'est vrai
aucune société n'a trouvé de solution
aujourd'hui à cette question efficace on
nous dise états unis quand on va voir de
près ce n'est pas le cas c'est cette
ambiguïté sur le sentiment d'insécurité
ça voulait dire aux français vous êtes
tous dans votre tête
rien dans la réalité et où du coup bas
les gens se disent ils ont rien compris
sont sur une autre planète et je crois
que ça nous a coûté cher non je sais
juste parce que j'ai un oeil sur la
caméra quand je voyais le rouge que
c'est sur moi je fais mon mari ça donc
c'est plutôt le tempérament de patrons
pas prouver plutôt de contester non non
vous pouvez y aller aussi
j'écoute pas forcément c'est vous savez
j'ai mon oeil comme ça non on est bon
[Applaudissements]
je te laisse à notre insu pénible et
vous écouter plus pas du tout du tout je
suis envoyé chez un grand professionnel
et présentez c'était au nom de l'humour
vient de vue de notre présent alors
pendant que jospin et bouquets risée à
matignon chirac s'installe dans ses
habits d'homme d'état ce que je pense
c'est qu'on a beaucoup sous-estimé
chirac et qu'on a cru que les histoires
d'affaires allait suffire que c'est bon
je pense que chirac avait beaucoup plus
de force qu'ont imaginé j'ai créé dans
mon livre qu'il était un peu maître du
temps et c'est un peu toujours lui qui a
imposé son terrain et ses idées je
prends un exemple on avait dit qu'on
accepterait pas l'euro sans condition on
arrive au moment d'une grande réunion
européenne s'appelle amsterdam ou non de
la cohabitation pas de vagues pourquoi
il est resté à matignon parce qu'en fait
c'est pas salé à rester il est hélas pas
par raison d'état par sens moral vous
pensez qu'il y avait sans doute il a dû
espérer qu'il serait le premier à
pouvoir être passé de premier ministre à
présent de la république
ça n'est jamais arrivé c'est dur
matignon honnêtement c'est dur et puis
quand en plus ils vous arrivent toutes
les tuiles qui lui est arrivé du genre
l'explosion de toulouse après les
inondations de la somme vous avez quand
même peut-être choses à traiter un sens
ce que n'ont pas les suivants oui mais
enfin il ya aussi quand même beaucoup
entretenu la croissance on est une
croissance alors là vous allez tous
râler mais plus supérieur à la moyenne
européenne et et ses poissons et cette
croissance c'est quand même une décision
de son gouvernement qu'il a permis ce
n'est pas un coup de bol il y avait un
peu de football est un plus
créée par son gouvernement raffarin lui
a pas de croissance le pauvre il fait
pas non plus grand chose pour la voir
notre problème alors votre bouquin a
fait un tollé général comme je les dis
en fait vous avez dit tout haut ce que
tout le monde pensait tout bas quoi
alors les gens vous sont tombés dessus
parce que vous avez transgresser la
langue de bois ce qui prouve que dans ce
pays on peut plus dire grand chose parce
que finalement ce que vous dit que
excusez moi oui j'y fasse est quand même
pas décoiffant à ce point non ça c'est 2
dans tous les cafés de france et de
navarre
et d'ailleurs enfin ce qui
m'inquièterait plus ce pour le tollé bon
c'est un tollé ce qui m'inquiète le plus
c'est cette espèce de discours convenu
il faut et après on s'étonne que les
gens aient l'impression que les
politiques leurs membres je vais été
lynché un peu mon non non non donc
sachez rompt pas non il ya des sifflets
quand je suis monté à la tribune à la
rochelle mais moi ça m'a pas choqué
parce que quand on dit les choses un peu
raide faut pas s'étonner qu'en face on
vous envoie des ripostes assez tonique
aussi un nom regardez magnéto serge
marie noëlle lienemann j'aime beaucoup
mais c'était quand même que marie noëlle
lienemann on est quand même sans
lesquels humide ça sert à rien et c'est
petit c'est en effet très très inélégant
d'attaqué des personnes et surtout de
mettre toute la responsabilité sur
lionel jospin et je pense que ce qu'on a
à faire c'est chacun à faire son
autocritique
plutôt que de critiquer le voisin si je
fais arrêter un élu elle l'aurait trouvé
une danse
non non pour être à nouveau me disent
nous avons engagé un travail de
réflexion des mises à plat ça ne passe
pas par les attaques personnelles qui
discrédite notre j'allais dire notre
propre corps le droit d'inventaire
existe de voir d'élégance il existe
aussi c'est tout pour éviter commander
en ligne allemand de trop craché dans la
soupe
surtout quand on a été un de ceux qui
ont fabriqué la soutenir moi j'accepte
les critiques simplement déjà j'aime pas
le terme cracher dans la soupe parce que
pour moi la politique c'est pas de la
soupe c'est pas je fais pas ça par
profession j'ai toujours été prof au
démarrage ait été à chaque fois que j'ai
été battu et c'est donc cette idée on
ait craché dans la soupe c'est le petit
univers à nous moi je vais vous dire la
seule chose qui traumatise c'est l'état
du vote le pen dans la société française
et ça plus personne n'en parle
aujourd'hui oubliées amnésie
oui j'aurais apprécié les nageuses pas
s'il avait gagné mais justement il
appelle la question que je me pose c'est
pourquoi on a perdu alors marie noëlle
lienemann à l'université d'été de la
rochelle a été sifflé un par un par un
pour vos amis quand vous êtes arrivé
c'était assez dur pour vous à ce moment
là vous accusé la presse d'avoir sorti
certaines phrases de leurs conseils
ce qui est pas très vrai je continue le
bouquin comme vous y allez pas de main
morte ouais mais pourquoi cette reculade
c'est pas vous salir les gens vous ont
bien vous avez vu les gens vous ont
encore rescif les circuits sont pas ils
auraient préféré que vous disiez qu'on
leur fasse ya un bras d'honneur ou non
parce que ce qui est vrai quand même
c'est que ce qui m'a sait pas que le
fait qu'ils reprennent et lille et les
phrases c'est même pas qu'ils aient
tribus et trahir la pensée ce qui ne
l'est réduite à cela et après on me dit
elle ne fait qu'attaquer de neige aux
pas non j'ai eu des réactions de lionel
jospin non non j'en attends pas
d'ailleurs je pense pas qu'il en aura
mais nous on l'a appelé au téléphone
magnéto serge oui alors franchement
marie noëlle c'était pas plus simple de
m'appeler pour me dire ce que tu penses
de moi plutôt que d'écrire un bouquin
je crois mais je vais vous dire je crois
parce qu'il a le moins apprécié de neige
aux parents fats dans toute cette
histoire c'est vos allusions à la taille
de son sexe magnéto serge qu'est ce que
tu veux dire par un peu court pour être
président vous savez qu'il admire il a
dit comme ça il l'a dit il a dit je ne
resterait pas éternellement muet vous
pensez qu'ils risquent de revenir loin
de séjour quand même je pense que
honnêtement quand il va revenir je pense
qu'il tira des choses c'est ce qui va
faire de vous quand il va revenir
regardez
et vous vous dites pas comment il
atterrit malheureusement les sondages
vous donne pas raison vous le savez
selon un sondage louis harris celui qui
incarne le mieux la gauche c'est fabius
oui après aubry et hollande savait bon
d'abord je pense que fabius et les
vraies qualités
cela dit ce que je pense c'est qu'il
faut se méfier des sondages parce que
les sondages donnaient lionel jospin lui
balladur et lui et on a vu les résultats
juste j'ai une question si je peux me
permettre
le j'avais j'ai lu où je sais plus qui a
dit que s'il avait fait drucker ça
aurait pu changer des choses c'est
ruckert qui a dit ça je ne sais pas mais
je pense qu'on fond quand j'ai vu madame
chirac chez drucker je me suis dit quel
marquer des points pour son camp et je
me suis dit qu'après tout justin aurait
peut-être été plus lui même plus proche
des gens ça suffit peu de gens qui s'est
vainement chevènement a fait drucker oui
c'était une bonne et lagat et j'ose pas
perdu à cause de deux cent mille voix
qui l'armée c'est celle au caire a osé
faire quoi maintenant vous n'êtes ni
député ni mer vers devenir prof de
physique-chimie
enfin pas de physique-chimie peut-être
je vais sans doute aller msha tant que
l'éducation nationale me confirme au
conseil national à au conservatoire
national des arts et métiers mais bon ce
n'est pas encore fini et puis je vais
continuer à faire de la politique
alors le journal libération a fait un
portrait de vous et lorsque le
journaliste de libération vous demande
quel est votre principal regret dans
votre carrière politique
vous dites personne ne me prendre une
femme d'état il avoue pleurer là je suis
une émotive et comment quand il parle de
regret je défile dans ma tête tout ce
qu'on peut regretter dans son existence
donc je vois bien une certaine
incompréhension parfois de ce que je
veux défendre et je me dis la méthode
est peut-être trop agressive et donner
en même temps je sens l'impérieux devoir
de dire ce que j'ai à dire
donc c'est ça qui me fait un peu cette
impression d'impuissance et de rage
devant les devants les choses et en même
temps c'est vrai que je trouve
dramatique qu'il faille avoir les
reinharc bien polis et bien rangé pour
avoir l'air de vouloir défendre l'état
et agir pour l'état et je crois avoir
fait mon travail de ministre avec un
certain sens de l'état comme les autres
et cette image tout le temps vous êtes
ces trublions
bon en même temps chaud quand je pense
qu'il faut déranger je considère qu'on
fait je lui dis un truc j'ai le même
problème
harry
dans l'inventaire
entretien avec frédéric geiger ne sait
jamais
m
ty noal on va faire un petit bilan
d'interview oui vous en pensez quoi
c'est une interview que j'ai dix ont dû
se dire qu'est ce qu'elle les polars
dans politique
et comment mais en même temps c'est
quand même ce que je suis ouais donc
voilà puis je vous redoutez terriblement
débat
ben oui avec le temps ça va vous
habituer oui je reste avec nous bien sûr
[Musique]
et maintenant
tout ça
la page
là
ouais si david lean et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à y bien plus d'un plot pour david
l'idée que pour un ministre de jospin
ses marques bien david pour rester dans
l'ironie facile avant de parler de vous
opposer des petites questions sur votre
petite famille dont il va votre papa
bien revient de vacances donc il doit
être bien j'espère à l'été prochain il
fait une tournée pour ses 60 ans et le
producteur de johnny hallyday jean
claude camus propose aux municipalités
de subventionner le spectacle contre
quelques milliers de places gratuites
est ce que vous trouvez ça bien avoir eu
c'est bien ça permet à beaucoup plus de
gens de pouvoir accéder à un concert où
les places sont quand même relativement
cher donc c'est plutôt une bonne chose
je trouvais normal que l'argent de la
mairie l'argent de la collectivité
servent à subventionner de géniale idée
plutôt que des spectacles culturels
non non plus marie mosquée de la place
pour tout le monde
vous étiez maire vous justement vous
auriez subventionner le spectacle de
johnny hallyday oui parce que je pense
que je n'ai l'idée c'est un phénomène en
france et que ce serait dommage c'est
des gens qui parce qu'ils n'ont pas
d'argent puisse pas les voir tout le
monde a droit à johnny hallyday
absolument c'est ça la gauche maman ça
va oui en fait toute la petite famille
comme ça quand on squatte ça va oui
c'est la famille nv cette famille à nous
comme une famille royale n'a pas droit
donc maintenant elle va mal famés l'idée
laura savard oui elle est en train de
tourner donc je suis très content parce
qu'elle commença dans une très bonne
comédienne il ya comme en salle est en
train de tourner son premier film
donc c'est un scoop pas bien ouais non
non je ne pouvais pas demander ce qu'il
faisait ma soeur et moi
bofill ça va il mylonas super estelle
très bien aussi ouais ouais
tout le monde va bien quoi il écoute
pour l'instant oui pourvu que ça dure
bon bah en fait
estelle s'était pas par hasard c'est une
façon d'arriver à votre nouveau disque
dans le thème principal mon cher david
et l'amour malheureux ça l'a toujours
été
ah bon toujours été comme ça vous étiez
heureux avec estelle vous faisais des
chansons d'amour malheureux bah oui
parce que ccc on parle de choses je
pense que les émotions passent par là où
ça fait mal en fait ça a toujours été
comme ça surtout dans la musique
donc je pense que en plus tout le monde
peut s'y retrouver quand temps en temps
quand il quand tout va bien comme on
vient de le faire il ya deux secondes
non il ya pas nécessairement beaucoup de
choses à dire c'est surtout dans plus
tôt la souffrance qu'on trouve un petit
peu tous ces sentiments là
[Musique]
lorsque
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
repenser saisie si tu veux c'est le
premier single du nouvel album de david
hallyday qui s'appelle révélations et le
texte est écrit par une fan
oui pegi pegi exactement pays si vous
suivez partout oui mais en fait non elle
ne suis pas partout elles étaient
surtout venus en tournée il ya deux ans
et demi on est parti sept mois en
tournée et donc au bout de trois quatre
mois j'ai on a tous remarqué qu'il y
avait que peggy était là tous les soirs
donc on l'a là je dirais ont là un petit
peu apprivoisé et donc qu'elle était
c'est comme ça alors là apprivoiser
parce qu'elle était un petit peu sauvage
et donc l aile
elle juste celle ci je vais demander à
la réalisation c'est d'éviter de faire
des plans où on te vois toi pierre en
bref si on pouvait passer par thérèse
entre les deux parce qu'il est très très
beau je vais pas m'en passe de l'un à
l'autre
ça va me rester règle contre les deux
terribles
serge le clip
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
extrait de son album
a sion
[Applaudissements]
quel sentiment avez-vous david à l'idée
c'est que votre père comme vous le
disiez bon il fait partie du patrimoine
de géniale idée mais il n'a pas écrit
beaucoup de musique et pas beaucoup de
texte dans sa vie il a fait au départ
beaucoup d'adaptations américaine qui a
pris la trouver des auteurs et des
compositeurs français et vous celle
inverse en fait vous écrivez depuis que
vous êtes tout petit je crois qu'à l'âge
de 7 ans vous aviez écrit une chanson
pour sylvie votre maman et vous écrivez
vraiment pressé votre truc
ouais ça a toujours été c'est le genre
de truc je pense qu' il n'y a pas
nécessairement une raison à tout et ça
c'est venu comme ça ça toujours été une
passion depuis depuis tout bébé je me
suis même pas posé la question
j'ai eu beaucoup de chance parce que
généralement on galère beaucoup se
demandant ce qu'on va faire dans la vie
et moi je ne sais pas vraiment pourquoi
on pourrait penser que c'est parce que
j'ai baigné dans une famille musicale
mais je pense que ça ça ne fait que 5 ou
10% du truc je pense que le reste
j'étais vraiment passionné et puis et
puis voilà quoi mais je voulais juste te
dire c'est quand même source avait très
difficile de rentrer dans le métier
peut-être moins beaucoup doivent se dire
ouais c'est facile on a un père qui est
une star machette ou mais ça va être
vachement dur d'arriver au niveau ou
parce que david à l'idée là quand il
rentre quand il remplit les salles et
tous et david hallyday c'est plus mais
je pense que je pense que c'est
difficile c'est un métier qui on le voit
un petit peu avec justement le bon côté
de toutes ces émissions comme pop star
star academy tous les trucs comme ça je
pense que les gens s'aperçoivent que
c'est difficile il c'est dur pour tout
le monde maintenant c'est vrai que
bon je pense qu'il faut travailler c'est
comme dans tous les métiers ça s'apprend
et je pense que du jour au lendemain on
réussit pas à faire quelque chose il
faut aussi prendre un pilote de formule
1 commence à conduire quand il a 10 ans
11 ans je pense que c'est dans tous les
métiers pareil et faut d'abord aimer ce
qu'on fait et puis après c'est la cerise
sur gâteau quand ça marche mais ça vous
est venu comment la politique à ces
jeunes que vous êtes contre et au ps
c'est l'âge de 20 ans donc moi ça m'est
venue un petit peu avant 68
le vietnam mais moi franchement je
pensais pas en faire mon métier 1
je croyais que j'allais marie curie moi
je voulais faire une grande invention
scientifique pour le bonheur de
l'humanité
bon eh ben j'ai fait autre chose mais
enfin j'ai aussi fait de la physique
chimie
il nous fait aussi des choses qu'on
galère l'humanité au moins voyez en tous
les cas n'ait retrouvé j'espère oui
peut-être pas toute l'humanité vers une
partie non mais c'est juju tout aussi
d'une famille où on avait des militants
politiques notamment ma grand mère qui
avait fait de la résistance 1 beaucoup
compté dans ma mon engagement personnel
elle a été à ravensbrück
du coup j'ai toujours pensé que défendre
ses idées était vital alors david c'est
marrant parce que vous avez une image
quand même assez un peu showbiz un peu
showbiz people vous avez fêté par
exemple votre anniversaire le 14 août
dernier
vaud 36 ans pas forcément people en fait
son adversaire 4 fêtait ses trente six
ans franck à saint tropez au vip avec
félix gray régine avec sandra bon coeur
albert de monaco et george michael c'est
un peu c'est vrai c'est un peu chaud
puis bolt maintenant bien sûr que
c'était en plus la première fois que je
le faisais moi je vais pas de chance moi
mon anniversaire il est en plein milieu
de l'été donc tout le monde tout le
monde part en vacances pour c'est la
première année vraiment je me retrouve
tout seul que je me suis dis bah tant
qu'à faire aller là où il ya du monde
ouais c'est vrai que l'an dernier par
exemple vous avez fait des photos dans
voici avec une dénommée vanessa non je
n'ai pas fait dont on appris on a pris
des photos et on a pris des photos avec
vanessa
c'est vrai que vous avez été longtemps
attiré par les filles un peu un peu
fofolle loin un peu
maintenant c'est vrai aujourd'hui j'ai
l'impression de vous chercher autre
chose votre femme idéale aujourd'hui ce
serait plus une mère de famille ah bon
non non je pense que en fait on
recherche toujours quelqu'un qui qui qui
nous ressemble en fait je pense que
c'est la difficulté c'est de trouver des
gens qui sont faits dans le même moule
qui aiment les mêmes choses qui me les
mêmes
qui ont les mêmes patients qui a envie
de faire les mêmes choses c'est vraiment
important donc
donc je pense que enfin moi en tout cas
je suis plutôt à la recherche de ça sans
être vraiment à la recherche je pense
que c'est quand on cherche on trouve
jamais ce qu'on veut donc
donc je disais ça parce qu'en fait
j'avais cette image comme ça c'est
normal vous êtes à un artiste de
variétés vous avez des commandes en
milieu de la chanson manière on dit on
dit forcément showbiz je pense que c'est
un petit peu le terme un petit peu
je dirais négatif un peu péjoratif
horrible et jour hâtif mais mais bon
c'est comme ça en fait c'est beaucoup
plus sérieux que ça vous pratiquez
toujours la méditation ou un peu moins
maintenant mais avant oui ça vous est un
peu passée où un petit peu ouais ou fois
temps en temps mais c'est quelque chose
qui m'a beaucoup servi
ça avait commencé sur le tournage d'un
clip 1 et quelqu'un vous avez dit tu as
une aura tu as quelque chose ça vous
avez intéressez vous étiez vous aviez
acheté des livres mais je m'intéressais
toujours un petit peu tout ce qui est et
ce genre de choses et puis surtout le
bouddhisme c'était assez particulier
comme ça toucher ni elle ni à la
religion
ni secte donc c'est quelque chose qui
était relativement pacifistes et c'est
ce que j'ai aimé un petit peu dans cette
philosophie est donc sam âgé comme
naturellement commencé à en parler avec
eux cette personne pendant qu'on
tournait le clip de hey justement et
puis après j'ai commencé à lire des
bouquins qui est vraiment m'intéresser
et puis j'ai découvert qu'il y avait une
espèce de vérité une simplicité qui
faisait partie de moi aussi qu est que
j'affectionnais particulièrement quoi
puis là maintenant ça te fait chier non
non ça ne fait pas chier non non non non
non non mais disons que j'en fais moi
maintenant quoi vous voulez parler de
votre père de la méditation
non non pas encore
david habib et vous avez essuyé les
plâtres d'une nouvelle interview qui
s'appelle l'interview miroir c'est bien
monter sur scène ça regarde david tu
cherchais quelqu'un qui te ressemblent
[Rires]
alors comment ça va ben écoute ça va
bien je suis un peu fatigué en ce moment
parce que bon de jumbo spaemann et puis
je me couche très tard mais sinon ça va
merci de va poser ses questions
tu es content de mon nouvel album ça
c'est genre de questions que j'aime pas
trop répondre
bah écoute ouais ouais ouais je pense
que on a mis pas mal de temps à le faire
donc je suis content la france n'en rate
un hockey la france a mis du temps at
adopté mais maintenant ça va
ouais mais ça a toujours été plus ou
moins dans la pas marre qu'on me parle
tout le temps de ton père non j'ai
beaucoup de chance j'adore mon père donc
non j'en ai pas marre dont ça va tu
pense qu'il vaut mieux être le fils de
johnny ou de sylvie ça c'est pas évident
à répondre non je suis content d'avoir
les deux le matin quand tu te regarde
dans la glace
est ce que tu te dis ouais cool je suis
david hallyday non non non je me dis pas
ça non je me dis que j'aurais mieux fait
de dormir deux heures de plus
est ce que tu vois un homme heureux en
face de toi ah ouais ouais je vois un
homme heureux en face de moi tout à fait
ça fait combien de temps qu'on s'est pas
retrouvée comme ça tous les deux ça doit
faire bien cinq minutes t'as pas envie
de casser ce miroir parfois si ça
m'arrive c'est comme tout le monde
est ce que tu viens pour les vacances
alors david habib et petit bilan
l'interview cette interview miroir c'est
difficile non non non les questions sont
quand même non pas si difficile que ça
non non mais ce qui est difficile c'est
un petit peu ce qu'on se disait tout à
l'heure c'est se poser des questions à
soi même des fois c'est difficile de
regarder la réalité en face est bon et
la musique c'est un véhicule
extraordinaire pour pouvoir le faire
justement pour le reste vous êtes
satisfait de la façon dont on a parlé de
votre nouvel album
ça va vous voulez dire ah oui oui la
promo est bien fait un là c'est sûr ça
fait très discret sur la famille ça va
non non non non
nickel tout va bien moi j'ai quand même
appris que johnny hallyday était ton
père est pourquoi il suffit que le
patois
mesdames messieurs
[Applaudissements]
on leur donne un petit coup alors
comment ça va bah écoute ça va ça va pas
mal tu es content de mon nouvel album
bah écoute ça s'écoute ça s'écoute pas
mal c'est un peu forcé sur sur la
guitare mais je trouve ça plutôt
sympathique
la france a mis du temps à adopter mais
maintenant
ça écoute ouais j'ai eu un petit peu de
mal mais quand on arrive des states
j'ai toujours un petit peu difficile
dans sa coutume et à la france donne a
pas marre qu'on ne parle tout le temps
de ton père
bah écoute
qu'est ce que tu veux moi ga père qui
est déclarée en douane ça intéresse tout
le monde donc forcément j'écoute pas
dans les émissions tu pense qu'il vaut
mieux être le fils de johnny ou le fils
de sylvie le fils de johnny mais pour
moi c'est plus facile de répondre ça le
matin quand tu te regarde dans la glace
est-ce que attend le matin est ce que
quand tu te regardes à glace est ce que
tu te dis que ouais cool je suis dit tu
vois c'est pas donné
le matin quand tu te regarde dans la
glace est ce que tu te 2 le matin quand
tu te regarde dans la glace est ce que
tu te dis cool je suis joniaux dîner non
cette offre les restos sérieux de ce
gros merde franck quand tu te regarde
dans la glace le matin est ce que tu
t'es dit ouais c'est cool d'être david
hallyday à l'époque où j'étais avec
estelle est ce que tu vois un homme
heureux en face de toi
oui d'abord envie de casser ce miroir
parfois tu rigoles ou quoi tu sais
combien ça coûte un miroir comme ça est
ce que tu viens pour les vacances
bah ça dépend qui c'est qui paye
[Musique]
m
la nati bien fait très bien cette
sécheresse toi aussi franck dubosc david
merci beaucoup et maintenant avant notre
invité suivant voici stefano forever
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà merci
non la troupe de stéphane aussi dans le
port et 20
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant dans cette émission qui
s'appelle tout le monde en parle
nous passons à la rubrique personnes en
part
[Musique]
ce soir là faire du meurtre au vatican
le 4 mai 1998
cédric tournay 23 ans vit ce caporal de
la garde suisse au vatican a tué aloïs
estermann le commandant de l'armée du
saint siège et sa femme gladys avant de
se suicider faux répond la mère de
cédric elle est là ce soir voici
muguette bodha
[Musique]
bonsoir muguette bauza marie noëlle
lienemann franck dubosc lagides à l'idée
merci d'être avec nous ce soir
alors la version officielle on la
connaît donc cédric tournay votre fils
était garde son supérieur et et aloïs
estermann alors cela loïs letterman il
faut savoir que si celui qui avait sauvé
la vie du pape
quand il avait été victime de la
tentative d'assassinât du turc ali axa
et le pape lui vouer évidemment une
reconnaissance éternelle c'est son homme
de confiance
ils l'emmenaient partout et ils
connaissaient ce aloïs estermann tous
les secrets évidemment du pape et tous
les scandales alors la version
officielle c'est que cédric se serait vu
refuser par aloïs estermann une
décoration
parce qu'il était rentré de deux
permissions 48 heures trop tard et donc
il aurait tué son supérieur hiérarchique
il aurait tué la femme de ses supérieurs
hiérarchiques de la dce et il se serait
donné la mort
c'est ça que vous contestez en fait j'ai
compté spis que ça déjà les 48 heures je
l'apprends dernièrement et ça n'a jamais
été 48 heures 48 heures ça serait
beaucoup d'entre eux un retard dans ses
les retards qu'on a pu lui donner c'est
de lui une minute à 15,8 donc la
médaille
d'après deux ans quand on signe un
troisième année la médaille vient
d'office dans la lettre que vous avez
reçu du vatican on allait du saint siège
nous annonçant la mort de votre fille
s'était adressé à chamorel donc alors
que effectivement c'est sous ce nom
qu'ils étaient connus aussi mais vous
dites que l'employé jamais craqué quand
m'a remis une lettre soit disant de
cédric et qui m'auraient appelé un chat
novell
ouais alors que ça fait dix ans que je
m'applique à montréal cette lettre vous
l'avez fait expertiser par des
graphologues et vous êtes persuadé que
c'est pas lui qui l'a écrite ou le
papier n'était pas le papier à lettres
qu'ils utilisaient les supports non plus
ce support n'a jamais été vu dans la
correspondance avec ses cernes ici c'est
pas un support habituel
une enquête du vatican est très négative
pour votre votre fils ils disent qu'il
était homosexuel
alors que vous vous savez qu'il était
fiancé avec une dénommée valeria et
aucun doute là dessus
non il n'y a vraiment aucun doute là
dessus tout ce qu'on a accusé
d'alcoologie sous qui peuvent être
toxiques comme un caractériel
c'est venu surtout pour faire taire la
maman donc à ce que chaque fois que je
disais non à quelque chose derrière il
arrive et ça leur vernis est arrivé le
kyste
oui le christ alors ils ont dit au
vatican qu'il avait un kyste gros comme
un oeuf dans le cerveau et c'est ça qui
l'avait rendu fou exactement mais
seulement
on me le dit enfin on me le dit même pas
parce que je la prends en même temps que
ceux qui lisent et jour non parce que
jamais personnellement dit quoi que ce
soit je prends tout pas la télé ou dans
les journaux
gros comme un homme de pigeons mais
seulement neuf mois après alors qu'ils
font leur sortie donc tout de suite le
lendemain
et là il aurait pu lui dire tout de
suite je répète compris mais neuf mois
après c'était vraiment la dernière
ressource isr est trouvé il ya un trou
dans le crâne aussi parce que c'est un
trou de 7 mm non pas de 9 mm 41 comme
adil enquête du vatican
donc ça fait beaucoup de points
effectivement qui sont suspicieux il ya
beaucoup de points la plus forte c'est
quand même la position la tête à la
sortie de l'avalon point encore regarder
si c'était une matière dure aux matières
plus moi qui ai les cuirs chevelus donc
ça c'est un peu un porte à faux
mais par contre la position de la de la
tête
on ne peut pas se suicider dans cette
position ouais vous refusez donc les
conclusions de l'enquêté du vatican je
refuse l'anc est pour moi il n'y en a
pas une enquête puisque déjà trois
heures après sans témoin visuel on peut
dire que il est mort donc on n'a plus un
mort est ce que j'aimerais dire c'est
qu'on ne permet pas à la maman de dire
donnez moi des preuves donnez moi quand
même quelque chose de tangible vous
accusez la mort il peut pas se défendre
donc c'est carrément vivant à dire
écoutez donnez moi simplement à semblant
de preuve à 1 126 cas la route et je
dirais oui je serais même contente au
début que j'ai commencé leur enquête je
suis quand même dit que j'arrêtais
travailler la mêlée pour ça parce que
j'ai voulu dire quelque chose qui jouait
pas et je me disais non moi je les
trouvais c'est lui qu'il l'a fait alors
on pouvait entamer notre procédure de
deuil
et puis dire il a faim il a pété les
plombs mais pour péter les plombs
moi je crois pas qu'on a un peu un coup
de folie
il est à ce moment là on a préparé il ya
une haine ils en choeur c'est vrai que
vous voulez partir oui satellites ont
quitté la gare de suzlon projet où il y
avait plein de projets il rentrait donc
lagarde était déjà derrière c'est pas
pour ça qu'il ne sait pas son travail
on n'aurait pas donné les grades de vis
caporal qui représente en suisse d'une
c'est pas en france et en suisse ça
représente quand même le grade de
sergent major un fou aussi qu'il avait
passé tous les examens pour entrer dans
la gare du vatican donc à l'époque il
avait trouvé parfaitement normal j'avais
6 ans laurent fau assassin et un suicidé
alors vous refusez les conclusions de
cette pseudo enquête comme vous dites
vous avez demandé au vatican un
supplément d enquête de la voc vos
avocats l'ont fait aussi ça a été refusé
et maintenant vous avez mis une requête
devant la justice suisse cois c'est à
dire qu'on est par g quand j'ai vu comme
ça se passait chez une deux avocats
romain et quand nous avons qu'un roman
on essayait de rentrer dans la quête le
vatican leur a dit que l' enquête est en
cours donc il faudra voir à la fin de l'
enquête pour qu'ils puissent participer
mes avocats donc lire vos contacts et à
seulement une visite utile de s'y est
terminée on archivé auprès plus rien si
votre fils n'est pas coupable du meurtre
d'aloïs est hermann et de sa femme
gladys
quel est pour vous l'hypothèse la plus
crédible aujourd'hui donc il ya
énormément parce que cette année mieux
de se créer un milieu où c'est qu'il ya
des des envies on ne vend pas dans l'art
hiérarchie sans marcher sur l'autre
monsieur letterman
déjà en disant qu'il a sauvé le saint
père je le conteste vous pouvez regarder
les images d archives il était en tout
cas son maître du chant père quand il
est arrivé c'est quelqu'un d'autre qui
s'est mis devant mais on lui a donné
comme une image de sauveur donc pourquoi
c'est leur problème et c'est pas mon
problème
on a dit qu à lui c'est ce terme n était
proche de l'opus dei que sa femme était
proche de la franc maçonnerie est ce que
vous pensez qu'ils ont été éliminés
peut-être à cause d'une guerre des clans
qui sévirait au vatican comme dans tous
les lieux de pouvoir
toute façon si on fait taire quelques
quelqu'un c'est qu'il ya des raisons
alors c'est vrai que en rentrant dans
cette histoire quand j'ai commencé je ne
pensais pas apprendre et savoir tout ce
que je savais j'ai perdu énormément
d'illusions et je m'aperçois que
quand on gratte y a rien derrière donc
c'était une guerre de pouvoir quand on
rentre dans une guerre de pouvoir avec
le pouvoir l'argent c'est une autre
dimension c'est la quatrième voire même
peut-être s'il existe est ça qui m
dimanche vous voyez qu'un jour vous
arriverez à tirer cette affaire au clair
mon but est au départ j'avais confiance
à la justice je dis bien jamais
confiance pendant trois ans j'ai gardé
confiance à la justice vaticane
j'étais sûr qu'elle m'aiderait je savais
qu'elle était muselée bien entendu mais
j'avais confiance et je me suis dit si
ça ne marche pas ma foi malheureusement
je devrais faire appel aux médias parce
que les médias on est critique on les
aime on les aime pas mais quand on sait
quand même l'intérieur solution et c'est
risque
à l'aube de ce millénaire c'est toujours
les médias qui doivent participer à la
justice alors que la justice fait pas
trop son travail mais c'est différent
marie noëlle vous êtes des questions à
poser un milieu de boda le vatican est
pas directement dans l'union européenne
mais quand même rattachée à à l'italie
et peut-être que de l'aide de la justice
suisse peut-être que la cour européenne
pourrait vous être l'ultime secours si
vous avez le sentiment que la vérité et
les enquêtes ne sont pas fait ça
évidemment sa part étrange quand on
entend comme ça c'est en tout cas
certainement une grande douleur de
perdre un enfant sans avoir la certitude
que ce qu'on lui mais comme
responsabilité n'est pas acquis ça je
crois que les procès en sorcellerie sont
toujours à bannir
et encore plus au vatican qu'ailleurs
franck c'est pas dangereux de s'attaquer
au vatican et bien au départ c'est ce
que tout le monde le disait ce que j'ai
dit faut essayer il faut que quelqu'un
essaye et l'approché il ya quatre ans
que je fais et je suis toujours vivante
alors où je devrais faire intentions
peut-être c'est quand tout sera fini
merci en tous les cas et puis on est
heureux
l'occasion de vous exprimer
d'impressionnantes
m
j'accueille maintenant livia bons amis
[Musique]
et
soir alors pour les jolies filles comme
vous j'ai un vidéo sampler maintenant
regardez bien mieux j'en ai un camp
c'est vraiment le coup de foudre
je sais très charmant alors comme david
alité vous avez eu des parents
extraordinaire bruno et michel que du
bonheur
votre mère antiquaires notre père
passionné des marx brothers et vous
écume y et olivia bonamy avec lui les
cinéma du quartier latin quand vous
étiez petit et autres points communs
avec david
vous avez été durant votre prime enfance
elle se demande ce que je vais dire vous
avez été durant votre prime enfance
extrêmement choqué par la violence des
dessins animés de walt disney vous ces
bandits j'estime vérifié par moby et lui
c'est une logistique
c'est vraiment quoique blanche l'âge
aussi c'était assurément les armes
terribles mais tous les walt disney sont
vraiment fait rire les enfants
c'est pour ça non mais c'est vrai ça
vous vous vraiment je me suis brisé
maintenant aujourd'hui cinq heures
maintenant c'est énorme je vais le
regarder je me disais c'est ce mec a été
terrorisée par orange
et olivier à ces bandits et dans le site
dont on va parler après qu'est très bien
d'ailleurs philippe perdues cheveux gras
un mouvement il ya la fin du film j'ai
pas tout raconter mais il ya un univers
un peu à la disney avec une biche
il ya une scène qui est très drôle mais
j'en dirai pas plus voilà alors olivier
à 8 ans vous rêvez de devenir danseuse
mais vous échoué au concours de l'opéra
à 13 ans de l'école de théâtre à saint
germain et c'est au théâtre d'ailleurs
que tout commencera puisque patrice
leconte vous demande de faire partie de
la pièce o rniche en tournée avec jean
claude dreyfus les jean benguigui
si vous arrivez comme ça d'un seul coup
en fait c'est un concours de
circonstances et il se trouve que
invisible un visa ni mon père qui
l'avait pas vu depuis longtemps lui
demander ses nouvelles tout ça tout ça
qu'est ce que tu fais qu'est ce que tu
fais et mon père a dit mais massive et
comédienne ils se trouvent et qui
cherchait des jeunes actrices pour
reprendre cette pièce en tournée je me
suis dit bon je vais tenter ma chance on
sèche ça a marché une bonne école en
plus mal alors au cinéma le succès
viendra avec le ciel les oiseaux et ta
mère de djamel bensalah où vous êtes la
petite amie de jamel debbouze un million
d'entrées voilà et puis après il ya eu
effectivement une pour toutes de lelouch
sur mes lèvres de jacques audiard et la
tient une question est alors un mélange
est demandé aux téléspectateurs
d'envoyer des questions
j'ai une question de l'or de bordeaux
qui dit envoyé par internet
est-ce que les téléfilms comme les
enfants dans les arbres ou les filles du
maître de chai vous ont servi pour votre
carrière olivia je sais papa lui répond
j'espère j'espère parce que j'ai essayé
de faire au mieux dans des téléfilms de
qualité ouais donc
vous n'êtes pas desservis en tous les
cas de je pensais faire de la télé vous
ne savez pas quoi répondre à cette
question mais apparemment la demoiselle
ne savais pas quoi poser comme ça
[Applaudissements]
alors aujourd'hui olivia bonamy vous
revenez dans un film de claude duty qui
s'intitule comme je les dix filles
perdues cheveux gras avec vous dans ce
film marina foïs amira casar charles
berling sergi lopez et léa drucker voilà
le pitch ses trois filles qui ont les
cheveux gras très grave parce qu'elles
ont beaucoup de problèmes et qu'elles
n'ont pas le temps de se les laver
voilà un très gros entre fantaisie
on va regarder à quoi ça ressemble
magnéto serge ya des petites plantes
issues de manioc de qu une heure ça
dérange vtt foutent de ma gueule
vous êtes complètement parano je n'étais
pas sur la tronche kaunas tu vas te
faire chauffer je vais repartir de zéro
avant ma fille ça va quoi être dur tu
faisais des produits d'arrêter le
oxygénée qu'est-ce que j'en fais moi
montre plein d'amour j'ai plus de chats
tue tout seul et je connais les hommes
plus j'aime mon chien
ben c'est pareil pour les chats la
galerie des artistes à la conte et
magouilles pas clair finir tu comptes
faire quoi histoire n'a rien
c'était courageux et spectatrices
perdu
pour un logement une fois du travail
c'est peut-être un boulot de combattif
reyel est comme ça ça lui qu'il fasse
simplement et crade demain matin je me
lève je suis si vous voulez vraiment
passé je t'avoue proposer quelque chose
enfin c'est provisoire si ce n'est pas
d'horaires [ __ ] c'était même quitté
conneries ça fait toujours mal
pratiquer une piteuse âcre des mecs
comme toi faudrait lévis et qui
l'attendait quand vous parlez là
alors ce film à lui seul film a eu le
week-end dernier le prix michel d'ornano
à deauville vous savez qui était michel
d'ornano des prix et vous absolument tvq
tu vois la mer de deauville dans le prix
d'ornano à deauville voilà alors tué en
traversant la route de manière tout à
fait stupide alors donc que votre
personnage c'est quelqu'un de très doux
très violent qui au début elle travaille
dans un dans un hypermarché le fait de
la promo de la paella c'est terrible ce
qui est elle pète les plombs et c'est le
cas de le dire d'ailleurs elle se met la
tête dans le four de se suicider tout
explose son jules et vitrifié contre
lequel un popb périple elle ce quinze
jours dans le coma ont passé une
histoire il ya vous donc ce personnage
là très très fille perdue
marina il ya marina foïs qui est une
fille absolument bien sous tous rapports
c'est à dire qu elle veut elle veut elle
veut elle toujours aidé toujours donné
et finalement c'est quelqu'un
d'alcooliques qui n'a que sa vie dans sa
vie un chat et amira casar qui est une
espèce déjanté à la marianne faithfull
un peu coquille coq est un peu bloqué un
peu coquet mais quand vous voulez parler
de la drogue oui et on se remet à
d'accord je suis qui cherchent une voie
là et alors effectivement amira est avec
charles berling qui est parfait dans le
film vraiment les acteurs sont
extraordinaires charles berling en
patron de galeries défoncé branchés
comme ça terrible léa drucker excellente
excellente qui fait votre votre soeur
qui a kel sida et c'est la première fois
que je vois un film où j'ai pas que ça
fait rire m'enfin on joue avec ça et
c'est assez nouveau
et puis sergi lopez qui lui fait plutôt
l'intello le bourg
ou qui reçoit des masaï chez lui c'est
très très très marrante il s'est fait
avec beaucoup de beaucoup de soins enfin
ce claude duty a fait beaucoup de courts
métrages d'ailleurs une version 21
courts métrages mais alors c'était un
film et les chansons à ce pas une
comédie musicale c'est plutôt une tragi
comédie avec des moments chantés plutôt
qu une tragi comédie fantaisiste
ouais mais temps en temps elle change de
temps en temps mais dès que ça va mal
mais que ça normal en fait c'est
vraiment le ce qu'on pourrait pas
montrer en images on exprime dans les
chansons en fait
[Applaudissements]
il a tué
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et yann abattoirs tournoi quant à gap et
procure doute y étiez
le bonheur
c'est ici et corps a lieu
tu veux bien que ton ami nous en est
non
[Musique]
t
tout seul
sans toi
profits perdus chevrin de peu d'outils
avec entre autres livia belem
et l'australie
et ce soir voilà
c'est la rentrée
oui vous avez pris de bonnes résolutions
va falloir en prendre voici l'interview
bonnes résolutions de la rentrée
[Applaudissements]
olivia bonamy pour cette rentrée est ce
que vous avez décidé d'arrêter de fumer
non j'ai moi même et je suis une petite
fumée parce qu'en général tout juste de
cigarettes de plaisir à fait d'accord
est ce que vous avez décidé de grossir
un peu pour donner une chance aux autres
filles
pourquoi parce que à côté de vous ils
ont peu de chance même si je mange
beaucoup parce que je mange beaucoup
bon ben voilà ça va prend pas toujours
un peu là quoi est ce que vous avez
décidé de faire un enfant
ah oui ça de toute façon un jour a pas
cette année là est ce que vous êtes
décidé d'arrêter de vivre dans le péché
non vous avez décidé olivia bonamy cette
année de vous taper jean yves le fur
comme toutes les autres filles de vous
taper gens arrivent le cuir comme toutes
les autres filles qui s abat vous
connaissez pas encore il s'est tapé
toute la gonzesse un toutes les actrices
je pense que ça ne se passera pas par ça
se passera pas par est ce que vous avez
décidé cette année de prendre un nom
très connu pour avoir des rôles encore
meilleur est ce que est ce que vous êtes
décidé d'arrêter des émissions de télé à
la con bon moi je suis ici ce soir donc
donc non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
damian un email
à beaumont
agwai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui c'est bien
jack est maintenant yann moix
[Musique]
sa bonne amie marie noëlle lienemann
franck dubosc david hallyday voilà donc
il y en a près jubilation vers le ciel
après les cimetières sont des champs de
fleurs après anissa corto ou publiez
votre quatrième roman qui s'appelle
podium alors pour la sortie de l'anis à
corto vous aviez fait passer une annonce
viennent dans la presse avec appelle moi
et monique chevet d'un mois sans fait
appel moix avec votre numéro de portable
alors résultat beaucoup de lecteurs de
têtu le fameux magazine gay vous ont
téléphoné il ya une fille quand même qui
vous a téléphoné en me levant j'ai envie
de toi est vite et vous avez compris
quelques jours plus tard que c'était
trois copains du figaro en fait que vous
avez fait une sale blague
est-ce que ce soir vous êtes prêts à
recommencer à donner à l'antenne votre
numéro de portable
yann moix 06 62 37 61 60
est-ce qu'on pourrait avoir un petit
replay serge s'il te plaît
06 62 37 61 60 lots d'olivia bonamy
achevé de noter alors bien alors on
arrive à la question désormais chaque
semaine dans cette émission il y aura
une question qui s'appelle la question
[Musique]
alors cette semaine j'ai hésité entre la
question trop con pour que je vous la
pose moi même et la question de claire
chazal et finalement j'ai choisi la
question de claire chazal
attention vous êtes prêt yann moix
attention est ce qu'on peut dire yann
moix que podium et le roman de la
rentrée à l'ewi je crois que c'est le
moment de la rentrée
ouais je suis en fait je suis tout
beaucoup trop modeste pour me comparer
aux écrivains français est mort alors si
je me compare aux écrivains français
vivant on peut effectivement dire que
c'est le roman la rentrée et ce qui est
paradoxal c'est que c'est bizarre parce
que c'est un roman sur les saisies
claude françois claude françois alors si
bizarre c'est moi qui parle des yéyés et
si les romans de la rentrée qui sont
vieux de 30 ans à côté ouais je vous ai
préparé vos formules pour les vous allez
faire c'est bien vous avez regardé le
show pendant les vacances
en tous les cas vous êtes sur la liste
du goncourt maintenant le tout c'est d'y
rester le plus longtemps possible
c'est un peu comme un cheval de rodéo
oui c'est comme un jeu un peu télé où il
faut pas tomber
voilà c'est ça vous n'êtes pas très
souriant c'est vrai vous n'êtes jamais
très souriant et j'ai appris en lisant
paris match que quand vous étiez petit
on vous avait mis des bagues sur les
dents vous appelez d'ailleurs la banane
metalik sculpteur un surnom et zip et
halles centrales nucléaires etc
ces plaisanteries vous n'avez plus le
comme vous avez pu le faire mais vous
avez le mas si je souris toujours mais
par les yeux par les oreilles par les
cheveux par les mains mais j'arrive plus
à sourire par la bouche qui a peu
paradoxal par là j'essaye de me forcer
et ça se voit soignez les programmes et
de la rue ne vont pas trop mal
je peux pas y arriver moi je peux pas
moi c'est pas pareil comme un animateur
télé c'est même ce qui préfère garder
sabatier vous l'avez eu ça aussi voulait
et c'est à peu près tout vous avez ça
allait les bagues sur le camp de casques
à huy ah oui au fait le cas il va
l'espèce de quintiq les dents et un jour
j'avais ça je dormais avec une amie
d'une part entre as dit à tes coups de
ton koopman en fait c'était un truc
c'était pire il alors passé un podium
ian le pitch deux podiums c'est
l'histoire d'un sosie de claude françois
effectivement qui s'appelle bernard
frédéric et puis il a un copain qui
s'appelle jean baptiste cousseau dit
couscous qui est le narrateur lui c'est
un ex sosie de claude françois mais il
est recyclé en sosie de ces jérôme sinon
2d jérôme ce qui vient après lui viendra
torture je le vivrais très très drôle
alors ce bernard frédéric basse et un
sosie dissidents en nonne agréé par le
club officiel en soi mais c'est ça
qu'elle est saisie officielle et se dit
freelance voilà alors il doit
effectivement refaire tous les concours
parce qu'il veut participer à l'émission
d'evelyne thomas que nous saluons ici
c'est mon choix
voilà un et donc été obligé de retourner
un petit peu à l'école des sosies de
passer des concours
les titres de chaque chapitre sont des
chansons de claude françois
c'est un bel exercice exact il ya même
une chanson qui s'appelle hip hip hip
hourra
oui qu'il a une chanson de gainsbourg
qu'il avait enregistré en 67 et
lorsqu'elle plus drôle c'est les entrées
de chapi toutes ses phrases que vous que
vous relever de la bouche des sosies il
y en a un qui dit j'efface et bernard
frédéric qui dit j'ai toute la vie de
claude françois devant moi oui
d'ailleurs j'ai voulu qu'elle se livre à
cause de deux phrases comme on dit dès
sa vie claude françois avec qui j'avais
déjeuné et la phrase qui a tout
déclenché c'est un sosie qui apprennent
pas à m'avoir parlé de claude françois
pendant une heure et demie me dit tu
sais jan je suis beaucoup mieux dans ma
peau de peach et dans celle de claude et
un autre un autre déjeuner me parle
pendant une heure et demie et à la fin
du déjeuner me dit cette phrase démente
et là je me suis décidé à écrire le
roman il me dit s'y prête un creux de
françois comme les autres c'est pas la
peine
j'avais mon sujet même si c'est françois
était claude françois dès sa naissance
mois il a fallu que je travaille comme
un malade pour rattraper mon retard
il ya vraiment des perles et puis
pendant le concours aussi font donc le
concours vont participer pour devenir un
vrai sosie pour participer à l'émission
d'evelyne thomas et il dit le prof dit
c'est pas parce que vous êtes des sosies
qu'il faut copier tu en examen comme
l'irak ou voilà l'un qui disent que je
préfère en moins c'est claude et depuis
j'en ai eu notre fabuleuse qu'on a bien
saisi mais je peux plus l'intégrer dans
le roman et c'est trop les dix ans moi
quand françois serait resté claude
françois vous étiez à ce moment là j'ai
compris que je tenais non seulement un
sujet de roman mais un thème universel
finalement thème universel d'autant que
aujourd'hui on est dans la le terrorisme
de la célébrité en attendant la
démocratisation de la de la star et de
la célébrité mais c'est ça c'est
vachement intéressant de comprendre
qu'on est dans une époque où la
notoriété précède l'oeuvre et même
parfois la remplace c'est à dire que
avant on faisait une oeuvre une chanson
un livre et on devenait éventuellement
célèbre aujourd'hui on est célèbre
d'abord et on regarde ce qu'on fait il
faut remplir la notoriété de choses oui
on a un vase qui s'appelle la célébrité
on regarde ce qu'on peut mettre dedans
et si ça continue comme ça c'est les
inconnues qui vont devenir parfaitement
célèbre mêmes on dira dis donc t'es pas
inconnu toi
il y aura dans les boîtes de nuit des
vip very important people
soyons sûrs ont dans des carrés à cet
effet le dira que les gens qui ne sont
pas passés à la télé il y en aura plus
que cinq ou six plus vous citez souvent
l'exemple de david du loft qui dit moins
célèbres c'est ce que j'ai toujours
voulu faire et on va être non dire que
le fer et le lettres se sont venus
connexes et la célébrité d'anonymat sont
devenus synonymes
je sais par exemple depuis deux ans en
regardant les couvertures de télé 7
jours
mais ce sont des stars ont converti sept
jours parce que je ne les connais pas et
comme sont des anonymes je sais que
c'est des gens connus c'est vrai tout ça
se passe dans un univers très france
d'en bas de shopi shop de bricorama sans
mépris d'ailleurs devant
je vais pas mépriser l'endroit où j'ai
habité pendant 20 ans ouais dire près
d'orléans
je suis très province on travaille bien
que sur ce qu'on connaît après tout faut
que nerfs ne travailler que sur quelques
mètres carrés avec un champ de maïs une
grange et puis un fleuve pas loin puis
ça suffit pour faire un roman c'est même
trop mais c'est vrai que depuis
houellebecq qui a un temps danse comme
ça regardez la réalité dans les romans
oui je crois que la définition on peut
donner un écrivain c'est quelqu'un qui
nous parle du monde dans lequel on vit
actuellement
si c'est pour faire des livres qui
aurait pu se passer en 1936 c'est pas
tellement intéressant en fait
enfin tous les cas c'est un livre plutôt
bien ficelé une rentrée bien orchestré
les médias se sont fait l'écho qu'elle
le dit c'est le cas de le dire oui tout
va très bien mais mais un problème
lequel vous savez bien
je savais qu'il y aurait un problème est
là il ya pour la fusion improbable où il
va il y en a justement vous mettez les
homos à dos et oui et oui le personnage
bien sûr vous dis que c'est pas moi
c'est le personnage mais ça les gens
crédules sont pas dus et il vous en
veulent c'est vrai que ce personnage
très santoni est ce que s'en prend
violemment aux homosexuels
vous avez du pot parce que les phrases
qui ont été relevés par le magazine têtu
ne sont pas des pires non non rien à
bien pire
en fait je pars du principe que je n'ai
pas aimé les homosexuels et je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi si pour moi les
homosexuels n'existe pas exactement
comme les hétérosexuels n'existe pas je
considère qu'il a une sexualité par
personne puis la communauté homosexuelle
c'est quelque chose qui m'échappe comme
si par exemple dans une communauté d des
mecs à lunettes blond avec des doubles
foyer qui mettent des baskets adidas
je trouve que pourquoi non mais c'est
vrai c'est très étrange ce serait bien
il accuse à tort business à je trouve
que la sexualité quelque chose tellement
individuel que je pense que parfois il
ya moins de différences entre un
hétérosexuel et un homosexuel qui entre
deux homosexuels est donc tout
simplement il ya les individus qui
m'intéresse et comme il ya une sexualité
par individu j'ai pas à dire j'aime les
homosexuels cette phrase ne fait pas
sens chez moi exactement comme la phrase
j'aime ou j'aime pas les hétérosexuels
fait pas sens où les bisexuels les dans
la rome antique on faisait même pas ces
distinctions il n'y avait que la
sexualité quelque chose d'individuel
vous êtes courir vers écrire sans le
savoir elle a du bon mais il ya quand
même des phrases terribles vous dites je
ne suis pas homosexuel j'ai pas un
cancer du slip comme classe naomi je
recrute sun pages de thierry le luron
pas web violence
c'est à dire ça dans les romans français
et personnages appelle le sida un cancer
du slip parce qu'il parle de manière
très imagée et que je me suis amusé en
fait et y trouver un langage neuf
langues pour ce personnage dans les
romans burlesque en fait on fait souvent
ça et pour trouver ce langage j'ai
croisé le roman de renart et les
interviews de jean claude van damme et
ça donne ça on le connaît bien ici jean
claude van damme quand même
ils ont été laissés par ronan non plus
n'y avait pas à vous les pédales on peux
vraiment pas vous sentir déjà que dans
les hôpitaux on poireaute des plombes à
cause de vos filles ont infecté
c'est beaucoup mais attendez je précise
quand même que c'est mon personnage qui
parle et je sais j'ai essayé de faire un
personnage antipathique
non je crois que j'y suis arrivé là et
le mec le mec est radin dire qu'il va il
passe sa vie dans les restaurants à
volonté par exemple 25 fois une demande
de des suppléments viande jusqu'à temps
qu'ils meurent actuellement tout ce qui
est gratuit il est preneur nous et puis
en même temps je voulais rendre encore
plus antipathique donc en plus ils
homophobes on considère que l'homophobie
la radinerie sont parmi les défauts les
pires que puisse avoir un être humain
voilà j'en ai fait un personnage ou
moins dans tous les cas c'est un roman
très drôle très picaresque un peu
amphigourique de temps en temps ouais
non c'est le deuxième problème de la
soirée non non ça c'est un problème pour
moi le pas pour le bouquin on sait très
bien j'espère est ce qui est des sosies
de johnny hallyday beaucoup non oui je
connais ainsi johnny hallyday qui m'a
dit une phrase inoubliable il m'a dit je
suis bien content que johnny se soit
stabilisée senti mentalement parce que
j'arrive plus à suivre
j'ai cherché j'ai trouvé des photos d'un
sosie de david mais franchement je n'ai
pas invité ce soir parce que il est
beaucoup moins bon vous vous le
connaissez votre saisie non non pas du
tout non parce que michel sardou il
connaît son sosie ya eu plein de
problèmes avec son sosie dénommé quart
du serge cardu ouais ok en tôle avant
une enquête
le scoop vous connaissez pas le vote de
la prochaine fois je l'inviterai à huy
avec pc inpact de m'avoir invité
bosc et je pense que franck dubosc
viendra dans une autre émission pour
parler du boulot franck dubosc en tous
les cas vous montrer une érudition
extraordinaire sur claude françois vous
avez lu beaucoup tous les podiums qui
était son journal et le titre de votre
étude et mademoiselle âge tendre salut
les copains meilleur pour ce livre j'ai
lu la bible intégralement ce que j'avais
mais j'avais fait don quichotte et tous
les numéros deux podiums et tous les
livres que j'ai trouvé sur peau de
françois
ouais c'est ça un mixage de tout ça ça
donne un livre en fait oui parce qu'on
apprend beaucoup de choses sur claude
françois en même temps je dirais est
d'abord vous tordez le cou à cette
rumeur sur la mort de claude françois on
dit toujours la star a été électrocuté
par un godemichet dans son bain un
vibromasseur ni un vibrant basse alors
j'ai enquêté effectivement dans ce livre
il ya la description de la mort de
claude françois seconde par seconde et
un jour je me suis dit bon 7 tests
viraux minceur qu'est ce que je vais
pouvoir faire pour lui la guillotine est
et j'ai une idée toute bête chez les
avants rue saint denis dans un sex-shop
et sans parler de peau de françois je
suis arrivé j'ai dit un type voilà je
voudrais offrir un vibromasseur à ma
copine mais j'ai peur qu'ils aient des
problèmes est ce que parce que les
s'électrocuter autres ils vivent pas du
tout les défenseurs ça marche pas sur
secteur ça marche à piles
versailles est une légende s'évapore en
quelques secondes voilà c'est simple que
ça
à l'arrivée mort comment claude françois
c'est un obsessionnel un maniaque un
dingue et il ne pouvait pas supporter
par exemple que sur son bureau le crayon
de papier soit pas parallèles à l'angle
du bureau et c'était toujours comme ça
et donc kevin ampoules qu'il narguait
depuis des semaines et un jour il s'est
dit bon c'est elle ou moi ça peut plus
durer soit elle fait un effort elle se
rectifie d'elle-même soit je vais être
obligée de me lever et faire moi même et
ça il supportait pas les rapports de
comme il avait les pieds dans l'eau il a
appris le courant voilà alors il s'est
levé et il a reçu la lumière puisqu'un
livre christie qui ont une peau plus
c'est vrai bien cette érudition yann
moix on va les vérifier tout de suite
mais tout le monde veut jouer on va
faire un quiz cloclo ça s'appelle tulle
zhu attention attention dhabi vous êtes
prêts ouais mais c'est lui qui va gagner
c'est pas sur la potasse et non la date
de la mort de claude françois
11 mars 1978 13h50 jusqu'à la piscine
ah oui tout le monde se souvient de ce
qui faisait le jour d'avant tout
françois c'est un des problèmes du livre
parce que moi dans la piscine ils sont
passés à claude françois druet d'amour
et de décéder j'espère ils ont fait une
annonce dans la piscine quel âge aurait
aujourd'hui claude françois s'il avait
su changer une ampoule 63 ans puisqu'il
est né le 1er février 1939
ouais et après tu va nous dire que tu
vas pas gagner sur blanc qu'est-ce que
je vais être minable je crois on va voir
le métier du père de claude françois il
travaillait dans la compagnie du canal
de suez
il était contrôleur de la circulation
maritime sur le canal de suez
jusqu'en 1956 il est mort en 62 sans
avoir connu on en parlait tout à l'heure
on ne lui pas du tout la gloire de son
fils voilà son prénom était aimée bravo
nous rappelons les scores sous quel nom
claude françois at il enregistré son
premier 45 sous le nom de coco et se
sentant glace orthographié cas aux
accents circonflexes car aux accents
circonflexes et le titre dimanche jeunes
about to histoire mais attention les
deux versions une version en arabe et un
version en français et c'est l'inventeur
du rail pour moi en fait et le deuxième
disque c'était clair de le clair de lune
à maubeuge twist et mensah je sais pas
où a été enregistré cette chanson
ou de dix ans le pays et la ville
est-ce que j'hésite entre londres n'ont
aucun nom et la suisse non oui les gars
ce nom los angeles new york
non c'est une chanson de cui au départ
c'est c'est in the same old song c'est
la moutarde
hier matin donc la tomate à la cheville
non alors à los angeles
non non mais detroit
et voilà mais si me sylvie va chanter sa
honda demi point quand même ou par un
demi point mais là elle a chanté sylvie
ça ah bon je savais pas vous savez pas
non la dernière fois qu'il est venu j'ai
appris plein de trucs sur sa naissance
il survit enfants parce que évidemment
quand on retrouve les journaux de
l'époque on en sait autant que lui même
plus la preuve est donc sylvie à chanter
oui c'est la même chanson bien sûr une
photo magnifique de sylvie et claude
françois avec les gammes sur la plage de
deauville en 1973 fait de sauts de cabri
et cie vie est magnifique blonde et que
je peux presque jaune devant le ciel
bleu se détache magnifiquement et les
impassibles en tee shirt marin vas-y
rouge c'est extraordinaire mais moi j'ai
été longtemps amoureux d'elle j'ai moi
aussi j'adore et sylvie et moi j'ai
trouvé formidable quand j'étais petit
c'était mon amour quels ont été pour
claude françois les conséquences de
l'attentât de l'ira à londres en 1975
assez simple une bombe a explosé et
claude aurait dû mourir et une anglaise
qui a eu l'idée de génie de passer à ce
moment là entre la bombe et lui et
l'anglais est morte quelques heures plus
tard et claude françois avait juste à un
accro à sa chemise dans l'âme et blanc
et et s'agit moi et moi je voudrais
juste un des plus complets tympans quoi
je n'enregistre marché justice quand
tout ce qu'on vous excusez moi deux
secondes je sais vraiment si presque
fini excusez moi d'être que ce pardon
excusez moi excuses thierry ardisson
bonsoir excusez-moi d'intérêt
l'enregistrement d'émissions suis
vraiment désolé c'est je m'appelle
marque la vraie je suis un animateur à
succès d'une émission à montréal
l'émission de variétés et je me suis
permis parce que c'est votre première
émission ce soir de débarquer sur votre
plateau mais juste pour vous par les
deux petites secondes ça veut dire je
suis désolé c'est une réalisation les
anonymes font effectivement célèbre oui
mais non mais non mais je peux je suis
désolé de vous avoir interrompu sa
lettre elle correspond jour bonjour
bonjour bienvenue à paris bonjour franck
dubosc bonjour monsieur jean jacques
debout film bonjour bonjour bonjour
madame
bravo pour thierry ardisson mon sport
sain la bête
enfin je vois la cg dire non je pense
que j'ai dit mais j'ai dit que je
comprenais pas qu'on les canadiens
parlait que j'aimais pas leur accent
mais ça ça c'est vrai ça équilibre à 20
avant d'aller plus loin
avant d'aller plus loin c'est juste j
avec moi je suis venu de montréal et
j'ai avec moi une équipe de tournage
pour mon émission oui l'on se sente a
sûrement il s'appelle paul les procédés
concernent la démission l'émission
s'appelle le grand blond avec un show
sournois et c'est un secteur oui non
c'est très drôle et c'est très réussi
l'animateur et des patins et là j'ai
avec moi une équipe et on se demandait
si on pouvait faire prend deux petites
minutes de votre émission pour faire une
entrevue pendant votre émission est ce
que vous acceptez ça alors je partirais
l'équipe vous pouvez venir les gars
c'est acheter
mais oui alors
alors c'est vrai
adacore assez des trappeurs non c'est
pas d'être là placé mes cousins et cdc
des consanguins en tout cas c'est
compliqué à expliquer c'est une histoire
épouvantable et j'apporte est évidemment
parce que par politesse et par
délicatesse j'ai apporté des petits
biscuits des petits biscuits
non non non ben en fait l'ancienne
période de charlebois se sentaient
peut-être franck dubosc connaît les
maple leafs et des multi biscuits afin
d'y passer là encore si vous pensez vous
le biscuit singap l'amusé vous avec ça à
temps on voit que non non c'est pas vrai
ça c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai qu'on
les pende une relation amour-haine avec
thierry ardisson
c'est très compliqué expliqué jamais
revu j'ai peur de me faire lyncher
c'est l'humain pas lorsque vous vous
entends d'ici ça rien avoir à voir ça à
traumatiser quelques personnes la
question d'accent oui vous faites le
tout avec we are we ah oui mademoiselle
vous en prie a goûté à ça c'est
extraordinaire c'est qu'on va voir un
canadien dans la couche littéralement à
weedon alors comment ils te planter ta
promo le canadien je suis désolé seule
fabienne thibeault non c'est l'ancienne
période quand il y avait dix ans elle
aussi elle était l'amie de laurent
ruquier diane tell et de marc edouard
nabe et de marc edouard nabe
alors qu'est ce que vous faites non
c'est juste parce que j'ai mon petit
simplement moins évidemment portatifs de
voyage alors je l'installé si ça vous
dérange vous voulez pas du tout non mais
c'est interdit
ça va pas non mais ça va venir avec
annoncé c'est une question là nous on a
eu le pire en france oui qu'est-ce que
vous avez eu pire les allemands à les
animaux sociaux
écoutez est ce qu'on a le temps de faire
une petite entrevue ça va les autres
certain que ça vous dérange pas
et oui passé vous allez passer bon c'est
bon tellement joué avec du lait quand
même avec vous ici aussi c'est très fort
avec le whisky
alors mais ce que je peux vous poser une
question très franche et très direct et
en français s'il vous plaît allez vous
me répondre oui je réponds si par
exemple vous eussiez détester l'accent
arabe le riz vous dire non non non parce
qu'en france il ya un tel passif et la
guerre d'algérie alors qu'elle ait
jamais eu de guerre du québec baisse
encore de roland avis canourgue vous
savez une bourriche était en vacances
panneaux et des cousins alors écoutez
moi je sais pas si on peut faire juste
ce jusqu'à sion de de montrer aux
québécois quel personnage finalement
plein de compassion et d'empathie vous
n'êtes pas c'est vrai que vous êtes
comme ça oui vous êtes main douce heure
de tendresse d'un père de famille
exemplaire un amant extraordinaire par
les tirs et ouais c'est ce que j'ai lu
sur internet et donc pour propager et
pour essayer de vous refaire une image
au québec que je vais y aller avec des
petites questions toutes simples en
rafale
et puis on récit de vous refaire une
belle image au québec 120 volonté bon
d'accord alors d'abord thierry ardisson
considérez vous la télévision comme une
forme d'art
ça peut l'être oui par exemple ce qu'a
fait jean christophe averty la
télévision en france
c'était une forme d'art et vous vous
considérez vous comme un artiste
quand j'ai fait paris dernière c'était
artistes et que ça peut l'être oui ça
peut on laisser ça c'est beau ça il faut
déjà été violemment mais secrètement en
rage pendant une entrevue tout à l'heure
oui oui tout à l'heure j'ai interviewé
marie noëlle lienemann et quelqu'un a
coupé la climatisation du plateau ah oui
et j'ai trouvé ça un supporteur et ses
seins absolument avez vous déjà
secrètement était en érection pendant
une entrevue
pas une érection mais une demi gros
louis à wimille
ils sont en train d'arranger l'animal
aux collègues en or massif apparaît
plein de compassion et en action voilà
alors d'après vous pourrez être rue dans
la vie série en 10 ans faut-il toujours
nécessairement avoir son opinion sur
tout non non non ce soit je pense est
révéré vous provoquez vous fait a
provoqué un peu à votre image provoquer
davantage pour faire provoquer
qu'est ce que vous aimez pas dans la
provocation envers vous les moyens que
son emploi des fois oui les gens qui se
déshabille devant moi le soir quand je
rentre chez moi à nombreuses je trouve
ça pas bien c'est la supporter j'aime
pas ça vous pouvez pas su mélanger ce
même pas l'humiliation des autres est
maintenant la plus belle qualité que
vous avez hérité de vos parrains victory
juliette c'est gentil pour le goût du
travail
ah il est à charny comme vous mon père a
beaucoup travaillé oui beaucoup plus que
moi a considéré que vous travaillez pour
vous plus fine et pas autant que non non
et dans la télévision vous apporter la
gloire de pouvoir l'argent la réussite
duquel vous vous débarrasserez le plus
facilement aujourd'hui d'aucuns qui vous
effraie le plus souvent avancé par
saddam hussein ou george bush george
bush
ah ouais moi aussi au québec aussi
couler
[Applaudissements]
je m'adresse aux fans aux familles une
de vos fils devient de roupies
d'animateur de télévision à succès oui
bon là préféreriez-vous dans la loge de
monsieur drucker
monsieur x j ai monsieur lumbroso au
québec dans la mienne monsieur fogiel
ah oui à nice que rien
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je connais pas moi l'ambiance paquet
d'actions alors maintenant un peu
important de la politesse est ce que
vous préférez dans l'animation
oui qu'est ce que vous préférez dans
l'animation dire des conneries et tout
le monde les regarde
qu'est ce que vous détestez dans
l'animation qu'on arrive sur mon plateau
comme ça avant de faire
est-ce qu'on puisse réunir
oui est-ce que je peux je vais vous
quitter oui mais j'ai avant de vous
quitter j'aimerais juste vous chanter
une petite chanson de la céline dion un
oui sinon je déteste c'est oui mais
attendez ma relecture de la shoah
d'accord ok abbas a aussi juste oui
c'est céline faye un petit extrait pour
qu'on s'aime et puis quand d'accord
qu'on parle qu'on partage quelques
wilshere alors j'y vais maintenant
savourer tous il est sûr de moi je ne
sais pas
comme en libye
il a
i télé entre histoire
houdain amitié
mais je les remises vue
offrir ma vie
même si
pas de ma vie
c'est
je ne sais pas
et il a hésité
une histoire d'amitié et je suis
en plein océan
et je serai que mon corps
m
[Musique]
portez vous bien des six bâtiments
youtube à bientôt
m
bah voilà
un ami québécois bon ya de toute façon
j'avais fini avec votre livre aussi
n'ont jamais tu as fait c'est je vais
pas montré à la caméra
donc je vais montrer le livre de yann
moix et la caméra et vous aller
applaudir à tout rompre à
miam
[Applaudissements]
voilà
nous allons passer maintenant mesdames
messieurs au blind test
[Applaudissements]
il est même
pour participer au blind test avec nous
j'appelle un nouvel ami gaël leforestier
[Musique]
ban
bonsoir salut elle a rejoint france 2
cet été vous êtes avec nous pour cette
rentrée
oui c'est un plaisir mais c'est bien
vous verrez on est très bien c'est pour
ça que tous les animateurs sont là
oui mais il faut quand même temps on
veut plus partir ce qui fait qu'on est
tous là je voyais des animateurs sur
d'autres chaînes à wimille sont moins
heureux
c'est vrai ouais je peux vous dire j'y
étais il ya pas longtemps d'arrêt -
seront bien sûr mais j'ai pas voulu
partir alors ce soir blind test consacré
aux chansons interdites aux usa après le
11-septembre mais oui mais nous qui
vivons là bas aux platines
monsieur philippe corti
j'avais oublié
non c'est moi bien attention donc les
chansons interdites aux usa après le 11
septembre 2001
vous êtes prêt gaël concentré tout le
monde bien sûr chacun pour sa mère
installée chacun pour soi la habana oui
chacun soit calmettois l'obligé à
l'équipe là bas des milliers de comptoir
j'ai l'impression d'être est-ce que je
peux jouer mais bien entendu bien
entendu
méline vous apporte de quoi vous asseoir
attention
non
mais attention c'est la tap réduit
compte voilà donc un point pour gaël
leforestier bravo méline ma petite
méline que je retrouve avec plaisir
attention à ces décès
est-ce que c'est franck dubosc ou gaël
leforestier et catherine c ac dc va
faire un petit replay me dit catherine
barma voulait qu'on le fasse
je
assez léger
s'il ya trois mois je pense c'est gaël
c'est moi c'est moi alors ça compte ça
fait deux j'aurais donné mes points à
olivia donc de toutes façons c'est
gentil j'aime pas l'esprit de
compétition
tu as parlé de ce prix dans ce jeu
ouais
[Applaudissements]
sur france 2 maintenant on prend que des
mecs ils sont bombay sont bons je suis
là
[Musique]
comme j'étais un petit batteur et là il
c'est phil collins donc c'est un petit
peu normal on oublie que c'est injuste
mais la vie et on oublie les règles
essentielles ckoi soufflage père d'âge
ah ouais j'ai entendu souffler la balle
on évacue la salle plus
alors bon c'est comme ça c'est la
rentrée on prendra soin
on prend de bonnes résolutions mais
aussi de la ville de salé mais c'est pas
une raison pour souffler on continue
avec les chansons interdites aux
etats-unis après le 11-septembre qui en
ligne
vous savez pourquoi cette chanson était
interdite elle s'appelle ruby tuesday ce
qui veut dire noir mat
et pourquoi ça fait 3 pour gaël 1 pour
david est impérial l'environnement
d'elton john
c'est vrai turmel petite fille
il ya deux mois
je
notre ami québécois ce qui fait 5 pour
mademoiselle bonamy pas du tout
impartial
oui
quel oubli
françois henri de virieu avait choisi
cette musique pour l'heure de vérité il
ya très longtemps mais je suis content
démontré un très bon goût c'est gaël qui
viennent y avec trois points vous c'est
un socialiste l'américaine
[Musique]
quinn un autre mordu la poussière
interdite après le 11 septembre
[Musique]
hello
un jeu
dans le public a ri s'essayent my brain
maintenant mesdames et messieurs nous
arrivons au super banco il a tout gagné
ça absolument super quel que soit le
score des autres celui qui gagne gagne
tout c'est dur c'est dur un super banco
oui
[Applaudissements]
l'open gagner
mais bien entendu après le super banco
il ya le méga banques mais non thiery
quoi mais pourquoi parce que la vie est
injuste
bon ça va attention mégalo
oui
la poste
je le savais et par twitter voilà bravo
en tout les cas belle arrivée sur la
chaîne skynews l'annoncé fait un 7 d'or
pour ton émission de psycho et puis
voilà c'est tout de suite le reste voilà
mesdames messieurs les missions de
avec ce soir une au delà
gros trade center et la 47e étage chez
robert laffont
franck dubosc je vous ai pas raconté de
dvd
le cap 5 et le 6 octobre posée
et en tournée je renvoie comme à
bruxelles tout à charleroi le 18 à mon
commentaire
j'ai toute la liste cgt pôle épargne et
marie noëlle l'image
merci d'être venus la parlementaire
c'est raté
c'était ma part de vérité et je sois le
droit l'avant-garde maintenant
l'inventaire gérard est mort six marines
rêve david hallyday
l'album s'appelle
nation le single s'appelle report de
saisies
si tu veux voilà merci la vie
je le gras merci le code duty avec
olivia bonamy marina foïs amira casar
charles berling serge lopez sorti le 11
septembre et les arts
aussi et la bande originale du chum
formidable comme le lendemain de tout à
l'heure
pis perdues cheveux gras yann moix blanc
moment de la rentrée
déjà sur la liste du goncourt
ça s'appelle podium mais c'est
chez grasset merci d arreter avec you
again aussi merci de vous mon cher ami
québécois
merci aussi c'était une roma il
[Musique]
m
je suis
[Musique]
bush
m
[Musique]
rien